I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Angela, Angela. Jenna, Jenna. Today is Jim and Pam's wedding day. And we are celebrating. Cheers. That's my drink. Can you hear it? I sure can. I'm taking a picture of you. Okay, well, if you take a picture we can post this on Office, ladies, pod because I'm drinking out of a very special champagne flute. Tell them all about it.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。安吉拉，安吉拉。珍娜，珍娜。今天是吉姆和帕姆的婚礼。我们在庆祝。干杯。那是我的饮料。你听到了吗？我当然听到了。我在给你拍照。好吧，如果你拍了照片，我们可以把它发到《办公室》女士播客上，因为我正用一个非常特别的香槟杯喝酒。告诉他们关于它的一切。
It is, Jenna, can I say it's craptastic. It is the kitchiest thing you've ever seen in your life. It is a champagne flute, but the stem is a series of four glass hearts that are like hollow in the middle. Yes. And it's a very large champagne flute. I didn't have any champagne. So I'm actually drinking an old fashioned out of it. Is that weird? I think it's flippin' perfect. Thank you. Cheers to you. I wish we were in the same room today. Dang it. I know. You've got a glass of red wine, though, so. I came to Airwolf today. I said, Sam, Jenna is pouring an old fashioned into her Niagara champagne flute. What do we got here? And he goes, I think there's some stuff over there.
是的，珍娜，我能说它烂得很有趣吗？这是你一生中见过的最俗气的东西。它是一个香槟杯，但杯柄是一串四个中间镂空的玻璃心。是的。而且这是一个非常大的香槟杯。我没有香槟。所以我实际上是在用它喝古典鸡尾酒。这很奇怪吗？我觉得它简直太完美了。谢谢。为你干杯。我真希望我们今天在同一个房间里。该死。我知道。不过你有一杯红酒，所以。我今天去了Airwolf。我说，萨姆，珍娜正在把古典鸡尾酒倒进她的尼亚加拉香槟杯里。我们这儿有什么？他说，我想那边有一些东西。
I found a bottle of red wine and a croissant. Oh. So I'm feeling very fancy. You're very European, I think. Red wine and a croissant. I feel like I am. Well, let me tell you where I got this champagne flute. When we traveled to Niagara Falls to shoot this episode, the hotel put a basket in my hotel room with these two champagne flutes, champagne, chocolates, candies, nuts, like a whole welcome basket. And they were just so delighted that the office had come to shoot there. And I was so charmed by that. I thought it was the sweetest gesture. And so I ate all the food. I actually shared it with the hair and makeup ladies. And I took the champagne glasses home. And now here they are in all their glory. Yum.
我找到了一瓶红酒和一个羊角面包。哦。所以我感觉非常时髦。我觉得你非常欧洲化。红酒和羊角面包。我觉得我是。好吧，让我告诉你我是从哪里得到这个香槟杯的。当我们去尼亚加拉大瀑布拍摄这一集时，酒店在我的房间里放了一个篮子，里面有两个香槟杯、香槟、巧克力、糖果、坚果，就像一个完整的欢迎篮。他们非常高兴《办公室》能来那里拍摄。我被深深地吸引了。我觉得这是一个最贴心的举动。所以我把所有的食物都吃了。我实际上和发型师及化妆师分享了它。我把香槟杯带回家了。现在它们就在这里，展现着它们所有的荣耀。美味。
Jenna, I love this story so much. You are truly my BFF, because I would have done the same thing. I would have been like, these glasses are going home with me. Oh yeah, lady. I wrapped these up in a t-shirt and I packed them in my suitcase. It's amazing we have to post it in stories. You guys, Niagara Part 2, we're here to break it down for you. That's right. This is Season 6, Episode 5. It was written by Greg Daniels and Mindy Kaling and directed by Paul Feig. Let me give you a summary of what we'll be going over today. Last night, Andy slept on Pam's floor because he was recovering from his torn scrotum. Michael slept by the vending machines. Dwight hooked up with Pam's friend and Kevin is about to
珍娜，我太喜欢这个故事了。你真的是我最好的朋友，因为我也会做同样的事情。我会说，这些杯子要跟我回家。哦，是的，女士。我把它们裹在T恤里，塞进了行李箱。真神奇，我们得把它发到故事里。伙计们，尼亚加拉第二部分，我们在这里为你剖析。没错。这是第六季第五集。它由格雷格·丹尼尔斯和敏迪·卡灵编剧，保罗·费格执导。让我总结一下我们今天要讲的内容。昨晚，安迪睡在帕姆的地板上，因为他正在从撕裂的阴囊中恢复。迈克尔睡在自动售货机旁。德怀特和帕姆的朋友搞在一起了，而凯文正要
lose his shoes. How's that for like a headline? That's good. The wedding, which is happening today, is becoming even more hectic than enjoyable for Pam and Jim and ultimately they're going to take matters into their own hands. Meanwhile, Michael makes an unlikely love connection and the office gang surprised Jim and Pam with a celebratory dance. I love this episode so much. I know we both have said that, but this second part of Niagara is when all the heartstrings are pulled. I mean, it's so beautiful and cringy. It's fantastic. We had Greg Daniels on for Niagara Part 1. We talked about the whole entire episode, so if you guys haven't heard that interview, listen to it. Now we're going
丢掉他的鞋子。这作为标题怎么样？那很好。今天举行的婚礼对帕姆和吉姆来说变得比享受更忙乱，最终他们决定自己动手。与此同时，迈克尔建立了一段不太可能的恋爱关系，办公室的伙伴们用一场庆祝舞蹈给吉姆和帕姆带来了惊喜。我太喜欢这一集了。我知道我们俩都这么说过，但尼亚加拉的这第二部分是所有心弦被拨动的时候。我的意思是，它既美丽又尴尬。太棒了。我们在尼亚加拉第一部分请来了格雷格·丹尼尔斯。我们谈论了整集，所以如果你们还没听过那次采访，去听听吧。现在我们要
to break down the second part. We have lots of fun stuff to share. This second part of Niagara also features the part where Jim and Pam sneak off and have a wedding ceremony on Made of the Mist. That is my fast fact number one. We got a fan question from Ashlyn M. in Windsor, Canada. Did everyone get to go on location to Niagara Falls or was it just Jenna and John? Did you stay on the American side or did you get to go to the Canadian side as well? Well, like we said last week, Ashlyn, we shot the rehearsal dinner and the church wedding and the bulk of this episode in Los Angeles. The only people who went to Niagara Falls were me, John Krasinski, Mindy, Randy Cordray, who was our line producer,
剖析第二部分。我们有很多有趣的事情要分享。尼亚加拉的这第二部分还包括吉姆和帕姆溜走并在“雾中少女号”上举行婚礼的部分。这是我的第一个速记事实。我们收到了来自加拿大温莎的阿什琳·M的粉丝提问。每个人都能去尼亚加拉大瀑布外景地吗，还是只有珍娜和约翰？你们是待在美国一侧，还是也去了加拿大一侧？好吧，就像我们上周说的，阿什琳，我们在洛杉矶拍摄了彩排晚宴、教堂婚礼和这一集的大部分内容。唯一去尼亚加拉大瀑布的人是我、约翰·卡拉辛斯基、敏迪、我们的制片主任兰迪·科德雷、
our cinematographer, Randall Einhorn, our director, Paul Feig, and then a handful of crew members. And we went to the American side of Niagara Falls. And we only had, Angela, one day to shoot. One day to get all of that? Yes. And I'm going to tell you now a little bit about how it all went down because Randy had to do an insane amount of preparation to get us there. He sure did. And he shared with us, you guys, we're going to break it down for you. You know, originally, the network said that they wanted John and I to shoot this on a green screen at like a fake water tank on like a fakie boat in Los Angeles. Boo! Boo! Right? Yeah. Randy was like, no, no. So. Good for Randy. Yeah. So Randy set out
我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾因霍恩、我们的导演保罗·费格，还有少数几名工作人员。我们去了尼亚加拉大瀑布的美国一侧。安吉拉，我们只有一天时间拍摄。一天时间完成所有这些？是的。我现在要告诉你一点关于它是如何进行的，因为兰迪必须做大量的准备工作才能让我们去那里。他确实做了。他与我们分享了，伙计们，我们要为你们剖析。你知道，最初，电视网说他们希望约翰和我用绿幕在洛杉矶的一个假水箱里的假船上拍摄。嘘！嘘！对吧？是的。兰迪说，不，不。所以。兰迪做得好。是的。所以兰迪着手
to create a budget that the network would approve for me and John to actually go. Now Greg told Randy that he would like us to shoot on the Canadian side of the falls because that's the side that has all the fun kind of kitschy wax museums and the water park. And it had the look that Greg was going for. On the Canadian side. On the Canadian side. Okay. But Randy found out that Canada has this very strict one-for-one staffing rule. And what that means is for every person that he brought from our crew, he would have to hire a Canadian to do a job. So if we wanted to bring our regular makeup artist, we would have to hire someone locally, you know, for a different job. It didn't have to be another
制定一个电视网会批准的预算，让我们和约翰真正去那里。格雷格告诉兰迪，他希望我们在瀑布的加拿大一侧拍摄，因为那一侧有所有有趣的俗气蜡像馆和水上乐园。它有格雷格想要的外观。在加拿大一侧。在加拿大一侧。好吧。但兰迪发现加拿大有一条非常严格的一对一人员配置规则。这意味着他从我们的剧组带来的每一个人，他都必须雇佣一个加拿大人来做一份工作。所以如果我们想带我们的常规化妆师，我们就必须在当地雇佣某人，你知道，做一份不同的工作。不一定是另一个
makeup artist, but just there had to be like a one-for-one representation on this crew. Oh. We did not have the budget for that. Got it. He also said that Canada has a 14-day embargo on all equipment. So any costumes, cameras, props, we would have to send it 14 days ahead of time. Well, we couldn't do that because we were using all that stuff in Los Angeles. Right. So Randy got this approved. Great. We had the budget to shoot on the American side of the falls. But then there was a problem. The made of the mist, it's in like dual waters. Also, the made of the mist is owned by a Canadian company. So that was a whole thing that Randy had to work out. That's right, because he said they
化妆师，但只是在这个剧组里必须有一对一的代表。哦。我们没有那个预算。明白了。他还说加拿大对所有设备有14天的禁运期。所以任何服装、摄像机、道具，我们都必须提前14天寄过去。好吧，我们做不到，因为我们在洛杉矶都在用那些东西。对。所以兰迪让这个获得了批准。太好了。我们有预算在瀑布的美国一侧拍摄。但后来出了个问题。“雾中少女号”，它在双重水域。而且，“雾中少女号”是一家加拿大公司拥有的。所以那是兰迪必须解决的整个事情。没错，因为他说他们
leave Canada and then cross over into American waters. Yeah. And then they go back to Canada. Right. But then they do have a boat that will start on the American side or will pick up Americans and go back to the Canadian side. So you can ride it from the American side, there's limited access to those rides. Most of the rides start on the Canadian side. It was a whole thing. This is so complicated for a boat ride. I mean, while I was in my hotel room with my fancy champagne glasses, I had no idea everything that had gone on to get me there to that gift basket. Wow. Randy shared with us that there were a lot of people that made this amazing moment happen for Jim and Pam. We promised him we would
离开加拿大，然后穿过进入美国水域。是的。然后他们回到加拿大。对。但他们确实有一艘船会从美国一侧出发，或者会接载美国人并回到加拿大一侧。所以你可以从美国一侧乘坐它，那些游乐设施的通道有限。大多数游乐设施从加拿大一侧开始。这真是个大工程。这对于一次乘船游览来说太复杂了。我的意思是，当我在酒店房间里用我那精致的香槟杯时，我根本不知道为了让我去那个礼品篮所发生的一切。哇。兰迪与我们分享说，有很多人让吉姆和帕姆有了这个美妙的时刻。我们答应他我们会
give them a shout out. He said first he was in touch with the film commissioner there, Tim Clark. Randy described him as a fountain of resources. Tim put Randy in touch with the location manager, Michelle Barone. Randy was also in touch with Tim Ruddy. He was the vice president of marketing for the made of the Miss Steamboat company. Angela Birdie, the media director of Niagara State Park. She was a huge fan of the show and Randy said she helped a lot. Randy even had to write a proposal to the New York governor's office and there was a film liaison there named Pat Kaufman who helped Randy get it all done. He said this was the nicest group of people and they just really made it happen without
向他们致敬。他说首先他与那里的电影专员蒂姆·克拉克取得了联系。兰迪形容他是一个资源喷泉。蒂姆让兰迪与外景经理米歇尔·巴罗内取得了联系。兰迪还与蒂姆·鲁迪取得了联系。他是“雾中少女号”汽船公司的营销副总裁。安吉拉·伯迪，尼亚加拉州立公园的媒体总监。她是该节目的超级粉丝，兰迪说她帮了很多忙。兰迪甚至不得不写一份提案给纽约州长办公室，那里有一位电影联络员叫帕特·考夫曼，他帮助兰迪完成了这一切。他说这是一群最好的人，他们真的让它发生了，没有
them. This scene would not have happened. Wow. Well, listen, I have even more stories to tell about our adventures getting on this boat. I'll save them for the breakdown, but it was incredible. So let's move on to fast fact number two, which is a follow up on that horse going over the falls deleted storyline that Greg told us about in his interview last week. Remember that? Not only do I remember, I'm so excited. I brought the table draft script to our recording session so I could read the scene. What? Yes. Oh my gosh, this is perfect. I was just going to say, do you want to remind people what the story was? But you have it. You have it. I have it. I have what we read at the table read. Oh my
他们。这一幕就不会发生。哇。好吧，听着，关于我们登上这艘船的冒险经历，我还有更多的故事要讲。我会把它们留到剖析环节，但这太不可思议了。所以让我们进入第二个速记事实，这是对格雷格在上周采访中告诉我们的关于马掉进瀑布的删除故事情节的后续。还记得吗？我不仅记得，我还非常兴奋。我把剧本草稿带到了我们的录音室，这样我就可以读这一幕了。什么？是的。天哪，这太完美了。我正要说，你想提醒大家那个故事是什么吗？但你有它。你有它。我有我们在剧本朗读会上读的内容。哦，我的
God. This is an exclusive. Okay, here it goes. So in the table draft, Jim and Pam are saying their wedding vows. Jim is saying enjoy and in sorrow and sickness and in health as long as we both shall live, suddenly gasps race through the audience. The minister looks up and stops. The camera whips over to see a man leading a horse into the space. On top of the horse is Roy dressed in a suit. I have to point out Roy didn't even ride the horse into the church. He had like a guy bring him in as a guy leading him like he's someone is holding the reins walking him in. Roy yells wait. Pam has a horrified expression. Everyone is staring shocked at Roy who tries to keep the horse pointed at Pam. But the handler struggles
上帝。这是一个独家新闻。好吧，开始了。所以在剧本草稿中，吉姆和帕姆正在说他们的结婚誓言。吉姆说在欢乐与悲伤中，在疾病与健康中，只要我们俩都活着，突然观众中传来一阵喘息声。牧师抬头停了下来。摄像机猛地转过去，看到一个男人领着一匹马进入空间。马背上是穿着西装的罗伊。我必须指出，罗伊甚至没有骑马进入教堂。他就像有一个人带他进来，就像有人牵着缰绳领着他走进来一样。罗伊大喊等等。帕姆表情惊恐。每个人都盯着震惊的罗伊，他试图让马对着帕姆。但驯马师努力
to keep it pointed the right way. So like Roy has no command over this horse at all. The horse's tail whispers by Stanley's face who looks annoyed. Jim whispers to himself. Holy ****. What? They had an F bomb? They had an F bomb. Roy says Pammy, we lived together for nine years and did everything a man and wife do. Camera pans over to me ma. Pam is horribly uncomfortable. Roy you love me once and can you imagine ever seeing me again as your night on a white horse or a brown horse. People change and I have to if you have any second thoughts any at all don't do this thing. Pam I don't have any second thoughts Roy. I love Jim not you. I wish you had just called first. Long awkward pause. Then Roy says then
让它保持正确的方向。所以罗伊根本无法控制这匹马。马尾巴扫过斯坦利的脸，他看起来很恼火。吉姆对自己耳语。该死。什么？他们有脏话？他们有脏话？罗伊说帕米，我们在一起生活了九年，做了男人和妻子做的一切。摄像机扫向我妈。帕姆非常不舒服。罗伊你曾经爱过我，你能想象再见到我作为你的白马王子或棕马王子吗。人们会变，我也必须变，如果你有任何犹豫，任何一点，不要做这件事。帕姆我没有任何犹豫，罗伊。我爱吉姆，不是你。我希望你先打个电话。长长的尴尬停顿。然后罗伊说那么
I will leave you with this thought. You're making a mistake Jim seriously man. Roy get me out of here. That's what he says to the handler of the horse. Jim you could have learned to ride it you know that would have been a little less and then Pam goes Jim Jim Jim. The handler walks the horse away as Roy tries to keep his dignity. Oscar boo boo. Then the minister says okay where were we? He starts them back into their vows but the camera pans over to Dwight. Dwight is seated next to a wedding guest and says that is a powerful looking horse excuse me. He gets an idea he gets up and follows Roy out. Wow. Wow. Yeah and then the other scenes are the ones Greg talked about where Dwight convinces Roy to
我会留给你这个想法。你在犯错，吉姆，说真的伙计。罗伊，带我离开这里。这就是他对驯马师说的话。吉姆，你本可以学会骑它的，你知道那会少一点，然后帕姆说吉姆，吉姆，吉姆。驯马师把马牵走，罗伊试图保持他的尊严。奥斯卡嘘嘘。然后牧师说好吧，我们刚才说到哪了？他让他们重新开始誓言，但摄像机扫向德怀特。德怀特坐在一位婚礼宾客旁边说那是一匹看起来很有力量的马，对不起。他有了一个主意，他站起来跟着罗伊出去了。哇。哇。是的，然后其他场景是格雷格谈到的那些，德怀特说服罗伊
let him return the horse but then because he's seen all of this like historical footage of animals that can go over the falls and survive Dwight then tries to ride the horse over the falls but then he bails EMS like rescues Dwight but the horse goes over but the horse survives. Yeah it was a crazy storyline and Greg shared that they did end up cutting this but one thing Greg said in his interview really piqued my curiosity. I mean there were so many things but he said that you know this storyline wasn't cut until the table read which is about one week before we started shooting. Oh yeah. So we were very close to shooting and this entire time Randy had been prepping this episode as if a horse was going
让他把马还回去，但因为他看过所有这些关于动物掉进瀑布并幸存的历史镜头，德怀特试图骑马掉进瀑布，但他跳车了，急救人员救了德怀特，但马掉下去了，但马幸存了。是的，这是一个疯狂的故事情节，格雷格分享说他们最终确实剪掉了这个，但格雷格在采访中说的一件事真的激起了我的好奇心。我的意思是，有太多的事情了，但他确实说，你知道，这个故事情节直到剧本朗读会才被剪掉，那是在我们开始拍摄前大约一周。哦，是的。所以我们非常接近拍摄了，而这段时间兰迪一直在准备这一集，就好像一匹马要
to go over the falls and Greg even said like they went to Universal Studios and they saw a demonstration of a water tank and how the horse might fall into the water tank and I was like what. So I reached out to Randy Cordray. Angela I have to share with you how much prep he did on this horse scene that was cut. I find it fascinating. I still can't get over the fact that this horse story was a go until about seven days before we shot. I know. Alright here's the first thing that Randy said to me and I'm going to quote him. He said I had never been asked to create a scene of such complexity and magnitude. This was far beyond the scope of creating the rainy proposal rest stop or throwing a fake cat
掉进瀑布一样，格雷格甚至说他们去了环球影城，他们看到了一个水箱的演示，以及马可能如何掉进水箱，我当时想什么。所以我联系了兰迪·科德雷。安吉拉，我必须和你分享他为这个被剪掉的马的场景做了多少准备。我觉得这很迷人。我仍然无法接受这个马的故事直到我们拍摄前大约七天还是一个进行中的项目。我知道。好吧，这是兰迪对我说的第一件事，我要引用他的话。他说我从未被要求创造一个如此复杂和宏大的场景。这远远超出了创造雨中求婚休息站或扔一个假猫
into the ceiling or adding a soccer ball careening off of Phyllis's head or producing a Chloris Leachman Jack Black mini movie. I was fearful that our meager television budget was far too small to produce the needed quality to make this gag appear credible and above all funny. But he said nonetheless he moved forward as that was what he had to do. So he said the first thing he had to do was find a church in Los Angeles that could fit a horse through its front doors. That's how we picked the church. Yeah because Roy had to come in riding a horse so not just big enough to fit a horse but fit a man on a horse through the front doors. And I guess a man leading a horse. Imagine that scout. Imagine that. Are you
进天花板或增加一个从菲利斯头上弹开的足球或制作一个克劳丽丝·利奇曼杰克·布莱克迷你电影的范围。我担心我们微薄的电视预算太小，无法制作出使这个噱头看起来可信且最重要的是有趣的所需质量。但他还是说他继续前进了，因为那是他必须做的。所以他说他要做的第一件事就是在洛杉矶找一个能让马穿过前门的教堂。这就是我们选择教堂的方式。是的，因为罗伊必须骑马进来，所以不仅要大到能容纳一匹马，还要能让一个骑马的人穿过前门。我想还有一个牵马的人。想象一下那个侦察兵。想象一下那个。你是在
just measuring church doors? And then the people are like what are you measuring for? This makes the church choice make sense to me now because it was one level. There weren't like multiple steps you had to go up to get to the front door and they had two big doors. Yeah. For the horse. For the horse. All right. Then he went to Stargate International. They were our go to effects company. He was going to have to create the element of rushing water. He was going to have to have Dwight on the horse riding into that rushing water. Dwight bailing off the horse and being rescued. And then like a series of the horse in various poses to stimulate tumbling down the falls. Oh my gosh. And then Stargate would have to
测量教堂门吗？然后人们会说你在测量什么？这让教堂的选择现在对我来说有意义了，因为它是单层的。没有像你需要走上去才能到达前门的多个台阶，而且他们有两扇大门。是的。为了马。为了马。好吧。然后他去了星门国际。他们是我们首选的特效公司。他将不得不创造奔腾的水的元素。他将不得不让德怀特骑在马上冲进那奔腾的水中。德怀特从马上跳下并被救出。然后是一系列马在各种姿势下模拟掉下瀑布的镜头。天哪。然后星门将不得不
be able to composite all of these and put them behind Jim and Pam in the waterfall as they're getting married. Randy said the costs were astronomical. I was going to say I think our ending had to have been cheaper. He said he reached out to Universal Studios back lot because they have a location there called Lower Falls Lake which is basically that tank that Greg was talking about. It has an enormous green screen. It can be filled with warm water to a depth of about eight feet. But in order to make the water churn like to simulate the rushing water of the Niagara River. Their plan was to chain four jet skis to the side of the tank which would then run and create like a white water effect. So like listen
能够合成所有这些，并将它们放在吉姆和帕姆结婚时瀑布中的背景里。兰迪说成本是天文数字。我正想说我觉得我们的结局一定更便宜。他说他联系了环球影城外景地，因为他们那里有一个叫下瀑布湖的地方，基本上就是格雷格谈到的那个水箱。它有一个巨大的绿幕。它可以装满约八英尺深的温水。但为了让水翻腾，就像模拟尼亚加拉河奔腾的水一样。他们的计划是将四辆摩托艇链在水箱侧面，然后运行并创造出一种白水效果。所以就像听
to everything he's like I need four jet ski drivers. Then he had to contact the animal service company to talk about the horse and get this. I did not know this. Randy learned that you need a special stunt horse because horses actually don't like to walk in water on their own because they don't like to walk or run anywhere where they can't see their hooves. And he said when you see horses in a western movie like dashing across a river those are specially trained horses. So they had to like start that process immediately. Yeah, that makes sense. So we've got our jet ski drivers. We're training the horse to go into water. But for the digital element of the horse tumbling he said they were going
他说的一切，他就像我需要四名摩托艇驾驶员。然后他不得不联系动物服务公司谈论马，得到这个。我不知道这一点。兰迪了解到你需要一匹特殊的特技马，因为马实际上不喜欢自己走进水里，因为它们不喜欢在看不到蹄子的地方走路或奔跑。他说当你看到西部片里的马像冲过河流一样，那些是经过特殊训练的马。所以他们必须立即开始那个过程。是的，这有道理。所以我们有了摩托艇驾驶员。我们正在训练马进入水中。但对于马翻滚的数字元素，他说他们将不得不
to have to put a horse into like a green screen harness and then lift the horse on a construction crane against a green screen and then have a camera crew like shoot like 360 degrees around the horse so they could then make it look like it was tumbling. Like it would be a visual effect. They would never tumble the horse but they do have to suspend the horse. Sure, sure, sure. He said this also required like many weeks of training and preparation to make sure that the horse was not stressed, that it was okay being lifted up. So this whole time, yeah, there was a horse actor. Right. Learning how to get comfortable in water and being suspended in a harness from a crane. Yeah, that horse was prepping. Oh,
把马放进一个绿幕安全带里，然后用建筑起重机把马吊在绿幕前，然后让摄像组在马周围拍摄360度，这样他们就可以让它看起来像是在翻滚。就像它会是一个视觉效果。他们永远不会让马翻滚，但他们确实必须悬挂马。当然，当然，当然。他说这也需要几周的训练和准备，以确保马没有压力，它被吊起来没问题。所以这段时间，是的，有一个马演员。对。学习如何适应水，并被起重机上的安全带悬挂。是的，那匹马在准备。哦，
plus its heart. Yes. Then Randy had to find a stunt double for rain because obviously rain did not want to ride a horse into a tank of rushing water and jump off of it. So they had to find a special stunt double for rain. But he said they still needed close ups of rain's face so they were going to have to do that facial replacement effect. Oh my gosh. Or they replaced the stunt man's face with rain's face. Alright, in the end, Randy estimated that this two part episode with the church and the hotel and the Niagara and the cast and the extras and the animals and all the horse stuff, it was going to be about a million dollars more than our usual budget. Oh my gosh. And NBC said you can only have half that.
加上它的心。是的。然后兰迪不得不为雷恩找一个特技替身，因为显然雷恩不想骑马进入一个奔腾的水箱并跳下来。所以他们必须为雷恩找一个特殊的特技替身。但他说他们仍然需要雷恩脸部的特写，所以他们将不得不做那种面部替换效果。天哪。或者他们用雷恩的脸替换了特技演员的脸。好吧，最后，兰迪估计这个有教堂、酒店、尼亚加拉、演员、临时演员、动物和所有马的场景的两集，将比我们通常的预算多出大约一百万美元。天哪。而NBC说你只能有那一半。
And he was like, I can't do it all. Oh, on top of that, I forgot to tell you, Allison Jones told him David Denman is not available. He's shooting a movie in New Orleans. They will not let him leave. So they were also like trying to fight with this movie company to get David Denman out for a day so he could ride this horse into the church. Do you realize how happy Randy was when this gag got pulled? He must have like done a cartwheel down the hallway. Like I can't even imagine. It did not matter all of the time wasted prepping this. He was so relieved because he said that freed up the budget so that he could get John and I to Niagara to actually shoot on Made of the Mist, which was what he wanted more
他当时就像，我不能全部完成。哦，最重要的是，我忘了告诉你，艾莉森·琼斯告诉他大卫·丹曼没空。他在新奥尔良拍电影。他们不会让他离开。所以他们也试图和这家电影公司争斗，让大卫·丹曼出来一天，这样他就能骑着这匹马进入教堂。你意识到当这个噱头被取消时兰迪有多高兴吗？他一定在走廊里做了个侧手翻。就像我甚至无法想象。准备这个所浪费的所有时间都不重要了。他感到非常宽慰，因为他说这释放了预算，这样他就能让我和约翰去尼亚加拉，真正地在“雾中少女号”上拍摄，这是他想要的
than anything. And so he went back to NBC and he said, listen, if you had the budget for this horse business, you've got the budget to take these two and let them get married as they should on the boat with the real falls behind them. Oh, so this whole storyline gave him leverage as it turns out. Yes. NBC. Completely. So I hope y'all liked that because I was just like, oh my gosh, all this time all I was doing was like trying on different wedding gowns. And you know, that was my prep. It just goes to show how hard our team at the office was always working every week. Unbelievable. All right, let's move on to fast fact number
比什么都多。所以他回到NBC说，听着，如果你有这个马生意的预算，你就有预算带这两个人去，让他们像他们应该做的那样在船上结婚，身后有真正的瀑布。哦，所以整个故事情节给了他筹码，事实证明。是的。NBC。完全。所以我希望你们喜欢这个，因为我当时就像，天哪，所有这些时间我所做的只是试穿不同的婚纱。你知道，那是我的准备工作。这正好说明了我们在办公室的团队每周都在多么努力地工作。难以置信。好吧，让我们进入第三个速记事实，
three, which I'm calling wedding buzz. Lady, the Jim Pam wedding was such a crazy pop culture event. It was such a trip to be a part of it. Entertainment Weekly called and asked John and I to do a cover shoot the cover of Entertainment Weekly. So fun. I remember those photos. They were so cute. Oh, they had us in wedding attire. We're like smashing cake on one another's faces. It was crazy. Like when I was growing up, there was the General Hospital, the soap opera. Yeah. Luke and Laura were finally going to get married. And it was like on the news. Luke and Laura from General Hospital, they're getting together. That's what this was like. This was like Jim and Pam were everywhere.
我称之为婚礼热潮。女士，吉姆和帕姆的婚礼是一个如此疯狂的流行文化事件。参与其中真是一次奇妙的旅程。《娱乐周刊》打电话要求约翰和我做封面拍摄，《娱乐周刊》的封面。太有趣了。我记得那些照片。它们太可爱了。哦，他们让我们穿上婚纱礼服。我们就像在彼此脸上砸蛋糕。太疯狂了。就像我成长的时候，有《综合医院》，肥皂剧。是的。卢克和劳拉终于要结婚了。这就像在新闻上一样。来自《综合医院》的卢克和劳拉，他们要在一起了。这就是它的样子。这就像吉姆和帕姆无处不在。
You guys really were. And Jenna, when we were researching this episode, guess what I found? What? I found on YouTube video they filmed while you and John were doing your photos for Entertainment Weekly. Oh my gosh. Is there anything we can say that is that we're not supposed to say? Can we tease anything? Something. Jenna's pregnant in real life because she's helping. Oh, you mean about the show things I shouldn't tell. Oh, God. John. Oh, man. You're not even showing yet. No, I am. I'm wearing a really tight corset for this photo shoot. It's my big secret, which is that. You're that method of an actor. Yeah, I'm that method of an actor. I'm also getting married. But that was an internet
你们确实是。珍娜，当我们研究这一集时，你猜我发现了什么？什么？我在YouTube上发现了一个视频，是在你和约翰为《娱乐周刊》拍照时拍摄的。天哪。有什么我们可以说的，我们不应该说的吗？我们可以预告什么吗？一些东西。珍娜在现实生活中怀孕了，因为她在帮忙。哦，你是说关于节目中我不应该告诉的事情。哦，上帝。约翰。哦，伙计。你甚至还没显怀。不，我有。我为这次照片拍摄穿了一件非常紧的紧身胸衣。这是我的大秘密，就是那个。你是那种方法派演员。是的，我是那种方法派演员。我也要结婚了。但那是一个互联网
dating situation. I did. I put out an ad. As soon as she found out that Pam was having a baby, she said, who wants this? Which I thought was a little crass. No, that was who wants this? That was my time. Who wants this? And then it showed you holding a baby and then a lot of news responded. Yeah, I'll say Kevin goes through quite an ordeal at our wedding about that. Yeah, I'd say and Andy as well. I'd say that Michael's dating life is expanded beyond our wildest dreams. That is very true. Very true. That's a good one. It's a good one. It's a good teasing. A tease. Very good tease. Teasing. I don't know what this is, but that's what you do when you tease. Nice.
约会情况。我做了。我发了一个广告。她一发现帕姆要生孩子，她就说，谁想要这个？我觉得这有点粗鲁。不，那是谁想要这个？那是我的时间。谁想要这个？然后它显示你抱着一个婴儿，然后很多新闻回应了。是的，我会说凯文在我们的婚礼上经历了一场相当大的磨难。是的，我会说，安迪也是。我会说迈克尔的约会生活超出了我们最疯狂的梦想。这是非常真实的。非常真实。那是一个很好的。这是一个很好的。这是一个很好的预告。一个预告。非常好的预告。预告。我不知道这是什么，但这就是你预告时所做的。不错。
Ah, listen to that banter. I know. I'm going to put it in stories because it's so cute. You guys look so cute. Well, it's very funny to me because that is totally a representation of our personalities whenever we would be interviewed, which is that John is just making wisecracks and I'm like midwesterly earnestly trying to answer the reporter's question because the reporter had said like, is there anything you can tell us about this episode? And I'm like, must answer question. And John's just like having fun. And it's so funny. That's always how we were in interviews. And also, both of you had in your brain that you actually can't say anything. Yes. Greg would have told you guys do not say a word about any major
啊，听听那戏谑。我知道。我要把它发到故事里，因为它太可爱了。你们看起来太可爱了。好吧，这对我来说非常有趣，因为这完全是我们接受采访时个性的体现，那就是约翰只是在说俏皮话，而我像个中西部人一样真诚地试图回答记者的提问，因为记者曾说，关于这一集有什么你能告诉我们的吗？而我当时就像，必须回答问题。而约翰只是在玩乐。这太有趣了。我们接受采访时总是这样。而且，你们俩脑子里都知道你们实际上什么都不能说。是的。格雷格会告诉你们，不要说任何关于任何重大
storyline. I know. And so like John was so quick-witted, he could come up with a bunch of jokes on the spot. And I'm just like in my brain being like, what can I say? Is there something I can say? Must compute. I also wanted to share that Joya Balfour, who worked at NBC Digital once again, came through for us here at Office Ladies because she shared with me, Jenna, that NBC had built a whole wedding website for Jim and Pam. You probably remember that. Oh, I remember it because they created like a registry tab. And as a joke, they had like two household items that they said were fulfilled. And then they had like a fancy sports car. Yeah. So the original website was called helpertbeasley.com. That
故事情节的话。我知道。所以约翰反应很快，他能当场想出很多笑话。而我只是在脑子里想，我能说什么？有什么我可以说的吗？必须计算。我还想分享的是，再次在NBC数字部门工作的乔亚·巴尔福为我们《办公室》女士提供了帮助，因为她告诉我，珍娜，NBC为吉姆和帕姆建立了一个完整的婚礼网站。你可能记得那个。哦，我记得它，因为他们创建了一个注册标签。作为一个玩笑，他们放了两个他们说已经完成的家居用品。然后他们放了一辆豪华跑车。是的。所以最初的网站叫helpertbeasley.com。那
is no longer active. But Joya did send me all the archived images that they had for the website. I'm going to post it all in our stories. There was even a guestbook entry. And Joya shared with us that the writers from the show, they are the ones that did all of the copy, all of the messaging on the website. But I wanted to read you a few of the website guestbook entries. Oh, I love it. Congrats, you guys. Good to see Pam taking my sloppy seconds. Just kidding. Hey, hey. Guess who wrote that? I believe that's Meredith. That's right, Meredith Palmer. You're so lucky, Pam. Jim is going to be a very handsome groom. You're very, very lucky. Any guesses? Okay, I think that
不再活跃了。但乔亚确实发给了我他们为网站存档的所有图片。我会把它们全部发到我们的故事里。甚至还有一个留言簿条目。乔亚与我们分享说，节目的编剧们，他们是做所有文案、网站上所有信息的人。但我还是想读给你们听几个网站留言簿条目。哦，我喜欢它。恭喜你们。很高兴看到帕姆捡了我的二手货。开个玩笑。嘿，嘿。猜猜是谁写的？我相信那是梅雷迪思。没错，梅雷迪思·帕尔默。你真幸运，帕姆。吉姆会是一个非常英俊的新郎。你非常，非常幸运。有什么猜测吗？好吧，我想那
would either be Kelly or Phyllis. Phyllis. Okay, ready? I can't believe you're getting married before I am. I mean, I guess it makes sense. You are older. Congratulations. Kelly, that's Kelly. That's right. Congratulations. What color dress are you going to wear down the aisle? Okay, that's Angela. That's right. Okay. Some people think that buffets are cheap, but I actually prefer them over the small portions of a fancy sit down dinner. Oh, I don't know that one. Someone who's into food, but that feels like, is that like, I don't know. That is Kevin. Oh, Kevin. Okay, one more, one more. That could have been Creed. I feel like that could have been Creed. Food related could have been Creed. It also could
要么是凯利要么是菲利斯。菲利斯。好吧，准备好了吗？我不敢相信你比我先结婚。我的意思是，我想这有道理。你比较大。恭喜。凯利，那是凯利。没错。恭喜。你打算穿什么颜色的裙子走过过道？好吧，那是安吉拉。没错。好吧。有些人认为自助餐很便宜，但我实际上更喜欢它们，而不是精致坐下晚餐的小份量。哦，我不知道那个。喜欢食物的人，但这感觉像，那是像，我不知道。那是凯文。哦，凯文。好吧，再来一个，再来一个。那可能是克里德。我觉得那可能是克里德。与食物相关的可能是克里德。它也可能是
have been Oscar because he's kind of frugal, right? True. True. All right. Here's the last one. Pam, you are like a daughter to me and Jim is like a son. I'm so proud that my son and daughter are to be wed. Tis a thing of beauty. Glory be. I think that's Michael Scott. That's right. Aw. You did really good. I did. I know my wedding guests, I guess you really do. Well, listen lady, I think we should take a break and then we will really get into this part two of Niagara. I've got a lot of cool stuff, I think. Let's do it. We are back and we open with Andy riding in pain in her hotel room because Pam's the only sober person who can take him to the hospital for his torn scrotum. Yeah. She tries to call
奥斯卡，因为他有点节俭，对吧？真的。真的。好吧。这是最后一个。帕姆，你就像我的女儿，吉姆就像我的儿子。我为我的儿子和女儿即将结婚感到骄傲。这是一件美事。荣耀归于。我想那是迈克尔·斯科特。没错。啊。你做得真好。我做了。我想我了解我的婚礼宾客，我想你确实了解。好吧，听着女士，我想我们应该休息一下，然后我们将真正进入尼亚加拉的第二部分。我想我有很多很酷的东西。我们开始吧。我们回来了，我们以安迪在酒店房间里痛苦地骑着开始，因为帕姆是唯一清醒的人，可以带他去医院治疗他撕裂的阴囊。是的。她试图打电话
Jim to help her, but he's clearly drunky Jim. Jenna, this was a much bigger storyline that would have really shown Jim's night and where he was at. In fact, there was a talking head where he explained their night of drinking and I think you need to hear it. What? Yeah. In deleted scenes. Let's hear it. A bunch of us decided to go over the border to Canada for one quick drink. So I'm in a car with Michael and Dwight and we get to the border. Dwight refuses to relinquish the sidearm. So four minutes later, here we are. Wow. Yeah. Greg said in the commentary there were more scenes of the guys night out that they even like get Oscar in and they're
给吉姆帮她，但他显然是喝醉的吉姆。珍娜，这是一个大得多的故事情节，本来会真正展示吉姆的夜晚以及他在哪里。事实上，有一个谈话头，他解释了他们喝酒的夜晚，我想你需要听听。什么？是的。在删除的场景里。让我们听听。我们中的一群人决定过境去加拿大喝一杯。所以我正和迈克尔和德怀特在一辆车里，我们到了边境。德怀特拒绝交出随身武器。所以四分钟后，我们就在这里了。哇。是的。格雷格在评论中说，有更多关于男士之夜的场景，他们甚至把奥斯卡也拉进去了，他们
going to go to a club. Like it was a whole thing, but it ended up just being the scenes you see in the episode. Oh, wow. Well, Pam does end up driving Andy to the hospital. And Angela, I just want to point out Pam's glasses that she's wearing. I thought this was a great callback to the fact that she wears glasses at all. And remember we had the episode where she wears her backup glasses to work. But I think my question is, are these glasses better than her backup glasses? I thought she looked cute. Greg said in the commentary this was like a big thing for Greg. He really, really wanted Pam when she wasn't at work or somewhere out and about that she wore glasses. And whenever you could see
要去俱乐部。就像这是一个大工程，但最终只是你在这一集中看到的场景。哦，哇。好吧，帕姆确实开车送安迪去了医院。安吉拉，我只是想指出帕姆戴的眼镜。我觉得这是一个很好的回溯，回溯到她戴眼镜的事实。还记得我们有她戴备用眼镜去上班的那一集吗？但我想我的问题是，这些眼镜比她的备用眼镜好吗？我觉得她看起来很可爱。格雷格在评论中说，这对格雷格来说是一件大事。他真的，真的希望帕姆在不在工作或在外面时戴眼镜。每当你能看到
Pam with her glasses, Greg just loved it. So funny. I loved wearing them. Now I have to wear glasses all the time, but it was fun. I loved the scene between Andy and Pam. I thought it was hilarious when he was like, I was kind of doing your job. So, and she goes, my job? My job is to get married in the morning. That's my job. Data shared in the commentary that there were a lot of alternate takes where you guys didn't reference balls and scrotum so much, but that you ultimately used most of the references. And then Randy and her talked about the fact that our show pushed the standards and practices limit almost weekly. So I counted, Jenna. Oh my gosh. In this episode, we say scrotum
帕姆戴着眼镜，格雷格就喜欢它。太有趣了。我喜欢戴它们。现在我必须一直戴眼镜，但这很有趣。我喜欢安迪和帕姆之间的那一幕。当他说，我当时在做你的工作时，我觉得这太搞笑了。所以，她说，我的工作？我的工作是早上结婚。那是我的工作。数据在评论中分享说，有很多替代镜头，你们没有那么多地提到球和阴囊，但你们最终使用了大部分引用。然后兰迪和她谈到了我们的节目几乎每周都突破标准和实践限制的事实。所以我数了数，珍娜。天哪。在这一集中，我们说阴囊
five times, balls one time and penis one time. That's not very many. I know. I was like, that's not that bad. It's not as bad as when Phyllis got flashed. No. Well, ultimately Andy is going to spend the night in Pam's room on her floor. And my goal is going to spend the night in the vending machine area. Because Dwight has a lady. There's a sock on the door knob. Location alert. If you can call it a location. That vending machine area was actually an unused office at the hotel. And Michael Gallenberg's team had to dress it to look like like an ice machine vending machine nook. Here's my question. Where do you get an ice machine? Like a hotel ice machine? Like who do you call? Where? What is that?
五次，球一次，阴茎一次。那不是很多。我知道。我当时就像，那没那么糟。它不像菲利斯被闪光灯照到时那么糟。不。好吧，最终安迪将在帕姆房间的地板上过夜。而我的目标将在自动售货机区域过夜。因为德怀特有一个女士。门把手上有一只袜子。位置警报。如果你能称之为位置的话。那个自动售货机区域实际上是酒店里一个未使用的办公室。迈克尔·加伦伯格的团队必须装饰它，让它看起来像一个制冰机自动售货机角落。这是我的问题。你在哪里得到制冰机？就像酒店制冰机？就像你给谁打电话？哪里？那是什么？
How do you do that? I'll tell you what, if anyone knows where to get an industrial size ice machine, it's our team at the office. Clearly. Oh, I want to say I do believe that's filled with fakey ice. Oh, it was. They said that on the commentary. It's fakey ice. Yeah. Well, now we're coming up on one of my favorite scenes in this whole episode. Is it Kevin at the front desk? Yes. Did you notice? And I know this was just Brian being Brian. How hard he hit that little dingbell. It scared the crap out of those ladies. Kevin is looking for his shoes. He left them outside his hotel room to be polished. But the hotel manager, the amazing Nicholas Schaefer, who plays the hotel manager, he's
你怎么做到的？我告诉你，如果有人知道在哪里可以买到工业尺寸的制冰机，那就是我们在办公室的团队。显然。哦，我想说我相信那是装满了假冰。哦，它是。他们在评论中说了。那是假冰。是的。好吧，现在我们要进入这一集中我最喜欢的场景之一。是凯文在前台吗？是的。你注意到了吗？我知道这只是布莱恩做布莱恩。他敲那个小铃铛敲得有多用力。它吓坏了那些女士。凯文在找他的鞋子。他把它们留在酒店房间外擦亮。但酒店经理，扮演酒店经理的了不起的尼古拉斯·谢弗，他
so good. Informs Kevin that they were so smelly that they made the decision to incinerate them. It was a safety issue, Jenna. It was a safety issue. The only thing missing to me in this scene is Angela Martin in the background, smiling ear to ear, feeling so affirmed. She's been talking about Kevin's smelly feet for years. Oh, Angela is delighted. She is so happy. Somewhere she's so happy. Well, the idea that they were going to have to burn Kevin's shoes because they were so smelly was our writer, Charlie Grandy. And my friend, Michelle Gunn, who played the front desk clerk, she told me that she improvised the line, we can offer you a complimentary breakfast. But get this, Angela, do you know how she
太棒了。通知凯文它们太臭了，他们决定焚烧它们。这是一个安全问题，珍娜。这是一个安全问题。这一幕对我来说唯一缺少的是背景里的安吉拉·马丁，笑得合不拢嘴，感觉如此肯定。她多年来一直在谈论凯文臭脚的事。哦，安吉拉很高兴。她太开心了。在某个地方她太开心了。好吧，他们不得不烧掉凯文的鞋子，因为它们太臭了，这个想法是我们的编剧查理·格兰迪提出的。而我的朋友米歇尔·冈恩，她扮演前台职员，她告诉我她即兴发挥了那句台词，我们可以为您提供免费早餐。但听着，安吉拉，你知道她
got the idea to improvise that line? No. This is very similar to how you created sprinkles. She was doodling on a post-it note at the front desk as a bit of business. And she was writing comp breakfast to room on the post-it note. And she said on one of the takes, Paul Feig just let the camera keep rolling for a really long time after the manager. That's what they would do on our show. Yes. So after the manager told Kevin that they burned his shoes, there was just this very long pause. And so Michelle saw her sticky note and said, we can offer you a complimentary breakfast. And then Brian improvised, okay. And she said it felt so good to be a guest actor on the show and get to contribute in such a fun way.
是怎么想到即兴发挥那句台词的吗？不。这和你创造斯普林克尔斯的方式非常相似。她当时在前台的一张便利贴上涂鸦，作为一点生意。她在便利贴上写着房间免费早餐。她说在其中一个镜头中，保罗·费格在经理之后让摄像机继续滚动了很长时间。这就是他们在我们的节目中所做的。是的。所以经理告诉凯文他们烧了他的鞋子后，有一个非常长的停顿。所以米歇尔看到了她的便利贴，说，我们可以为您提供免费早餐。然后布莱恩即兴发挥，好的。她说作为节目的客串演员并以如此有趣的方式做出贡献感觉真好。
She said our show was really special like that because she's been on other things. And she was like, you know, at this point, she had done several scenes and she had been working with Paul Feig now for a couple of days. And she was like, I don't know, I feel like this would be okay. I just love that. That just goes to show again how our show was so welcoming and such a creative collaboration. And I love it. Well, the next scene is Dwight wrapping things up with Isabelle. She slept over in his room. Michael is waiting out the hallway. This made me laugh so hard, Jenna. I got so tickled. As he walks up, Michael says, it's about damn time. I haven't gone to the bathroom in a day and a half. I know. I thought the
她说我们的节目真的很特别，因为她参加过其他节目。她说，你知道，在这一点上，她已经拍了几个场景，并且她已经和保罗·费格一起工作了几天。她说，我不知道，我觉得这会没事的。我只是喜欢那样。这再次证明了我们的节目是多么受欢迎，以及多么具有创造性的合作。我喜欢它。好吧，下一幕是德怀特和伊莎贝尔结束事情。她在他的房间里过夜。迈克尔在走廊里等着。这让我笑得太厉害了，珍娜。我被逗乐了。当他走过来时，迈克尔说，该死的时间到了。我一天半没上厕所了。我知道。我想那
same thing. I was like, you've been around a lot of restrooms. I mean, surely there's one off the lobby. I think it meant he hadn't gone gone. Do you know what I mean? Oh, he hasn't. Oh, yeah. He hasn't gone number two. Right. He hasn't had a private space. He hasn't. And that just cracked me up. He's so grumpy about it. They then go to breakfast and Michael is so disgusted. Look at how Steve looks at rain as Dwight. It is so funny. Dwight is just shoveling all this food in his mouth. They shared in the DVD commentary that Phil Shea had like 100 pancakes ready to go because you know how rain was in those scenes as Dwight? He eats. He was going to destroy it. Yeah. Like he would eat a lot.
一样。我就说，你肯定去过很多洗手间。我的意思是，大堂外面肯定有一个。我想他的意思是还没“去过”。你明白我的意思吗？哦，他还没去。哦，对。他还没上大号。对吧。他没有私人空间。他没有。这真的让我笑死了。他对此感到非常暴躁。然后他们去吃早餐，迈克尔感到非常恶心。看看史蒂夫看着雷恩饰演的德怀特的样子。太搞笑了。德怀特正把所有食物往嘴里塞。他们在DVD评论中分享说，菲尔·谢准备了大约100个煎饼，因为你知道雷恩在那些戏里饰演德怀特时是什么样吗？他吃。他要把它们消灭掉。是的。他会吃很多。
That was part of his like character thing. Remember when he ate all those bananas and he got sick? I do. But then they just sort of made it part of who Dwight was. Dwight even says he's ravenous after a night of love making. What about you? And then this is when we hear about Michael's European girlfriend. Yeah, exactly. I have some news. It's time to go to the church and I've got a location alert. If you are interested in getting married somewhere in Sherman Oaks, California and you need doors big enough to fit a horse, you can head on over to the church of the chimes on Magnolia Boulevard. We shot at this church on two different Saturdays. I mentioned last week we had to shoot on Saturdays because
那是他角色的一部分。还记得他吃了那么多香蕉然后生病了吗？我记得。但后来他们就把这变成了德怀特性格的一部分。德怀特甚至说他在一夜缠绵后饿极了。你呢？然后这就是我们听到迈克尔的欧洲女友的时候。是的，没错。我有个消息。是时候去教堂了，我有个地点提醒。如果你有兴趣在加利福尼亚州谢尔曼奥克斯的某个地方结婚，并且需要足够大的门来容纳一匹马，你可以前往木兰大道的钟声教堂。我们在两个不同的周六在这个教堂拍摄。我上周提到过，我们必须在周六拍摄，因为
that was the only day that we could get every single guest star together in the same room at the same time. The little ready room that I get ready with with my bridesmaids and my mom. That was one of the Sunday school classrooms at the church and they just kind of redressed it to look like a bride's ready room. And I don't know if you remember this about the location. We kind of talked about this with Greg. We didn't have trailers on site. So we just all kind of hung around on that patio and we talked about how Ed and Creed were playing music. Yeah, Ed brought his banjo. I think Creed had his mandolin. They had a little jam session and there was that grassy area. You see it in a few shots from the church
那是我们能让每一位客串明星同时出现在同一个房间里的唯一一天。我与伴娘和妈妈准备的小休息室。那是教堂里的一个主日学校教室，他们只是把它重新布置了一下，看起来像个新娘休息室。我不知道你是否还记得关于这个地点的细节。我们和格雷格聊过这个。我们现场没有拖车。所以我们都待在那个露台上，我们谈到了埃德和克里德是如何演奏音乐的。是的，埃德带了他的班卓琴。我想克里德带了他的曼陀林。他们进行了一场小型的即兴演奏会，那里有一片草地。你在教堂的几个镜头里能看到它
scenes and we just hung out there. It was really fun and it's one of my fondest memories of the whole run of the show. Now, do you remember when the paparazzi showed up? Oh, yeah, I do. Yeah, they were trying to take pictures of me and John in our wedding outfits. Yeah, they did. You know, the church is on a kind of a busy corner and Randy talked about it, that it was hard to make it private because it was on the corner of an intersection. So guess what, Jenna? They shared on the commentary and you probably remember this, that you and Paul Lieberstein decided to stage a photo. Yes. Oh my gosh. Yes, I remember that. Yeah, we thought, what if we do like a fakie, we were going to pretend like we were shooting
场景，我们就待在那里。真的很有趣，这是我整个剧集拍摄过程中最美好的回忆之一。现在，你还记得狗仔队出现的时候吗？哦，是的，我记得。是的，他们试图拍我和约翰穿着婚礼服装的照片。是的，他们拍了。你知道，教堂在一个相当繁忙的拐角处，兰迪谈到过，因为在十字路口，很难保持私密性。所以你猜怎么着，珍娜？他们在评论中分享了，你可能还记得，你和保罗·利伯斯坦决定策划一张照片。是的。天哪。是的，我记得。是的，我们想，如果我们假装一下，我们假装我们在拍
a scene and we were going to have me and Paul dressed as Toby run out of the church holding hands as if we had gotten married or as if he was stealing me from the wedding. We even had the camera guys pretend to shoot us so it would look like we were shooting and we wanted the paparazzi to take pictures of that so they wouldn't get a real spoiler. Well, they did. You guys clearly ran out the front doors and you hugged. There's like an embrace. I found the paparazzi photo that ended up in a tabloid. No. Yes, I did. I'll put it in stories. Fakie photo of Pam and Toby hugging and it's really funny, Jenna, because on the internet people were like, I'm sorry, why is Pam on a wedding dress? Why is she hugging
一个场景，我和打扮成托比的保罗手牵手跑出教堂，就好像我们结婚了，或者他正要把我从婚礼上抢走。我们甚至让摄影师假装拍摄我们，这样看起来就像我们在拍戏，我们想让狗仔队拍下那个，这样他们就不会拍到真正的剧透。好吧，他们确实拍了。你们显然跑出了前门，还拥抱了。有一个拥抱的镜头。我找到了那张最终出现在小报上的狗仔队照片。不会吧。是的，我找到了。我会把它发到故事里。帕姆和托比拥抱的假照片，这真的很有趣，珍娜，因为在互联网上人们说，对不起，为什么帕姆穿着婚纱？为什么她在拥抱
Toby? What's happening? Oh my gosh, that is so funny. I did not remember that party. Did not remember that it worked. It did. At the church, everyone is arriving. Phyllis's outfit is amazing. Giant hat, many feathers. I mean, it's a whole like pink suit hat. The whole thing. Mindy, I guess, had really wanted the character Phyllis to go all out. Like she wanted a huge like fashion statement outfit as if she was going to one of those big Southern weddings. Well, speaking of going all out, Kevin shows up with his hairpiece, but then he doesn't have his shoes. And this is where we see that he has made shoes out of a couple of tissue boxes. When he walks in and sits down next to Oscar and Angela, Jenna, we had
托比？发生了什么？天哪，太搞笑了。我不记得那个派对了。不记得它奏效了。确实奏效了。在教堂里，每个人都在到达。菲利斯的装扮太棒了。巨大的帽子，很多羽毛。我的意思是，这是一整套粉红色的西装和帽子。整套。我想明迪真的很想让菲利斯这个角色全力以赴。她想要一套巨大的时尚宣言装，就像她要去参加那些南方大型婚礼一样。好吧，说到全力以赴，凯文戴着他的假发出现了，但他没穿鞋。这就是我们看到他用几个纸巾盒做了鞋子的地方。当他走进来坐在奥斯卡和安吉拉旁边时，珍娜，我们
so much fun in the scene. It is such a small moment, but I want you to know it was so delicious when my character looks over at him and goes, oh my God. And then Oscar looks at him. We just had a blast. We got a fan question from Amy A. in Louisiana. Who came up with the idea for Kevin to wear tissue boxes to replace his shoes? And what were they made of? How did they make them basically? So it was Greg who came up with the idea of Kevin using the tissue boxes. And they were constructed using extra large Kleenex boxes. And Randy Cordray said that's an actual thing. This was not a fakie construction. They just bought giant tissue boxes.
在那个场景里玩得太开心了。这是一个很小的时刻，但我希望你知道，当我的角色看着他并说“天哪”时，那感觉太美妙了。然后奥斯卡看着他。我们玩得很开心。我们收到了来自路易斯安那州艾米·A的粉丝提问。是谁想出让凯文穿纸巾盒代替鞋子的主意的？它们是用什么做的？他们基本上是怎么制作的？是格雷格想出了凯文使用纸巾盒的主意。它们是用超大号的克莱内克斯纸巾盒制作的。兰迪·科德雷说这是真实存在的东西。这不是虚构的制作。他们只是买了巨大的纸巾盒。
Where do you buy tissue boxes that big? I don't know that, but they were fitted with flip flops inside. So that's how they stayed on Brian's feet. He said we had to make about 10 pairs of them because they did get beat up pretty quickly. Now you're going to see a bunch of little vignette scenes of everybody at the church. Michael has a talking head where he shares what he got Jim and Pam as their wedding gift. It's, it's, um, I am at a loss of words. It's a, it's a painting. He made it himself. He did it from memory. Right. He also has another version of this painting where they're nude. He's keeping that for himself. Right. Awesome. What? But here's a little tidbit.
你在哪里买那么大的纸巾盒？我不知道，但里面装了人字拖。这就是它们固定在布莱恩脚上的方式。他说我们不得不制作大约10双，因为它们很快就坏了。现在你将看到一系列关于教堂里每个人的小片段。迈克尔有一个谈话头镜头，分享了他送给吉姆和帕姆的结婚礼物。那是，那是，嗯，我无言以对。那是一幅画。他自己画的。他是凭记忆画的。对。他还有另一个版本的画，画的是他们裸体。他自己留着那个。对。太棒了。什么？但这里有个小花絮。
If you go to seven minutes, 35 seconds during this talking head, you'll notice that the stained glass window behind him is totally dark. There's no light coming through it, but he's lit up so bright. It's because you guys, we filmed this at night, but it was made to look like daytime, but you can't hide the stained glass. So if you look at the stained glass, there's no light coming through it. We got a fan question from Molly S in Bentonville, Arkansas, who is asking, who painted Michael's portrait of Jim and Pam? Well, it was created by an outside artist. Steve did not paint that. Uh, this was commissioned by Phil Shea, and it was actually the same artist that made
如果你在谈话头镜头期间看到7分35秒，你会注意到他身后的彩色玻璃窗完全是黑的。没有光透进来，但他被照得很亮。这是因为你们，我们是在晚上拍摄的，但它被做成看起来像白天，但你无法隐藏彩色玻璃。所以如果你看彩色玻璃，没有光透进来。我们收到了来自阿肯色州本顿维尔莫莉·S的粉丝提问，她问，是谁画了迈克尔那幅吉姆和帕姆的肖像画？好吧，它是由一位外部艺术家创作的。史蒂夫没有画那个。嗯，这是菲尔·谢委托制作的，实际上和制作那幅画的艺术家是同一个人
the clown painting that hung in Jim's childhood home. Oh, really? Yes. Randy said he is really bummed because he looked through all of his records and he cannot find the artist's name. So again, if you know the person or if you are the person who painted the clown painting and painted this portrait of Jim and Pam, we would love to hear from you. Randy also shared with me that there were 10 different versions of this painting that were made, all different. And then Greg picked this one. And after we used it in this episode, Greg hung it in his office until the end of the series, and now it hangs in his home office. Yes. So Greg has it. I loved all the scenes between Pam and her mom and her sister. They
挂在吉姆童年家里的那幅小丑画。哦，真的吗？是的。兰迪说他真的很沮丧，因为他查遍了所有的记录，却找不到艺术家的名字。所以再次重申，如果你认识那个人，或者你就是画了那幅小丑画并画了这幅吉姆和帕姆肖像画的人，我们很想收到你的来信。兰迪还和我分享说，这幅画制作了10个不同的版本，都不一样。然后格雷格选了这一幅。在我们在这集里使用它之后，格雷格把它挂在他的办公室里，直到剧集结束，现在它挂在他的家庭办公室里。是的。所以格雷格留着它。我喜欢帕姆和她妈妈以及她姐姐之间的所有场景。它们
felt so real. I mean, clearly Pam's mom is going through a thing. She's like, you don't have to go through with this. And then her sister's like, mom, you're being a drag, you're projecting, but it just felt so honest. I know. And then her friend is like, you know what? If you're good, I'm just going to go out and I'm just going to try to find Dwight. And Pam's like, wait, what? Pam's like, okay, wait, what? And then Chase is kind of after her to stop her and her veil gets caught on like, like a door hinge thing. Yes. We got a fan question about that. Rebecca R. from Sydney, Australia said, how many veils did you go through? I just love a deep dive on these kinds of costuming things.
感觉太真实了。我的意思是，显然帕姆的妈妈正在经历一些事情。她说，你不必非得这么做。然后她姐姐说，妈妈，你真是个扫兴的人，你在投射你的想法，但这感觉太诚实了。我知道。然后她的朋友说，你知道吗？如果你没事，我就要出去找德怀特了。帕姆说，等等，什么？帕姆说，好吧，等等，什么？然后蔡斯追着她想阻止她，她的面纱被门铰链之类的东西挂住了。是的。我们收到了关于那个的粉丝提问。来自澳大利亚悉尼的丽贝卡·R说，你们用了多少个面纱？我真的很喜欢深入了解这些服装方面的事情。
Rebecca, so do we. Well, I can tell you, this was very complicated, probably more complicated than I expected it to be even as the actor. It really was. They shared on the commentary that this was a three piece gag. Okay. First of all, you have the moment before the tear with the veil, then you have the actual tear, then you have the after tear. So to create these three beats, they had to use fishing line, special effects, a hook like thing on the door to snag the veil. It was weeks of figuring it out and timing it. Kelly Cantley, our assistant director, had to wear the veil twice as they tested it out. And they said, Jenna, they were really thankful because you really sold it. You really played out that
丽贝卡，我们也一样。好吧，我可以告诉你，这非常复杂，甚至作为演员，它可能比我预期的还要复杂。确实如此。他们在评论中分享说，这是一个三部分的恶作剧。好吧。首先，你有面纱撕裂前的时刻，然后你有实际的撕裂，然后你有撕裂后的效果。为了创造这三个节拍，他们必须使用鱼线、特效、门上的钩子之类的东西来钩住面纱。花了几个星期的时间来弄清楚并掌握时机。我们的助理导演凯利·坎特利在测试时不得不戴了两次面纱。他们说，珍娜，他们真的很感激，因为你演得太逼真了。你真的表现出了
your head was sort of tugged in a different direction as you were moving the other way. Yeah, it was crazy. We filmed the whole scene and I like didn't tear my veil at all. And then they actually connected me to the thing like the fishing line and the hook. So like I'm connected to it, but I'm pretending like I'm not. And then they sort of like pull the thing and I pull my head. And sometimes the veil wouldn't tear. So then we had to do like what Randy said a third time where they replaced my good veil that wouldn't tear with a torn veil to get like the after effect of the torn veil. It was a whole thing. It looks seamless. And it's sort of amazing how much effort it took to get that little moment. You know,
你的头在向另一个方向移动时被拉扯了。是的，太疯狂了。我们拍摄了整个场景，我根本没有撕破我的面纱。然后他们实际上把我连接到那个东西上，比如鱼线和钩子。所以我连接着它，但我假装我没有。然后他们拉动那个东西，我拉我的头。有时面纱不会撕裂。所以我们不得不像兰迪说的那样做第三次，他们用一个撕裂的面纱替换了我那个不会撕裂的好面纱，以获得撕裂后的效果。这真是一场大工程。看起来天衣无缝。为了那个小瞬间所付出的努力真是令人惊叹。你知道，
we also got a fan question from Emily Kay in Hugo, Minnesota. She's sort of asking me this question. Jenna is the dress that Pam wore, the style you would have picked out for her. I'm curious if there's anything you change about her look for the big day and how many meetings went down about what you would look like. Oh, Emily, so many things. So many meetings, Emily, so many, so many. So originally, Alicia Raycraft, our wardrobe designer and I, we had a little meeting and we were going to have her design Pam a wedding dress because Alicia is an amazing designer. But then we realized that Pam could never afford a custom wedding dress. So we stayed with the rule that our characters can only
我们还收到了来自明尼苏达州雨果市艾米丽·K的粉丝提问。她是在问我这个问题。珍娜，帕姆穿的那件婚纱是你为她挑选的款式吗？我很好奇你是否会对她大喜之日的造型做任何改变，以及为了你的造型开了多少次会。哦，艾米丽，太多事情了。开了太多会，艾米丽，太多太多了。所以最初，我们的服装设计师艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫特和我，我们开了一个小会，我们本来打算让她为帕姆设计一件婚纱，因为艾丽西亚是一位出色的设计师。但后来我们意识到帕姆永远买不起定制婚纱。所以我们坚持我们的角色只能
wear what they can afford to wear. So what we realized was that Pam would do what most brides would do. So Alicia and I went to David's bridal and we had a budget because you know the consultant is always like, what's your budget? We gave her a budget. She pulled a bunch of dresses and I absolutely loved this one. I mean, I thought it was perfect for Pam. We really tried to approach it like the character would approach it. You know, she had this pregnancy that she's trying to hide also that she has to make room for. So we got like a line dresses with a princess cut and this had that little extra bit of like, what do you call that, tool or whatever in the front? Yeah, like fabric to hide what
穿他们买得起的衣服。所以我们意识到帕姆会做大多数新娘会做的事。所以艾丽西亚和我去了大卫婚纱店，我们有预算，因为你知道顾问总是问，你的预算是多少？我们给了她一个预算。她拿出了很多婚纱，我绝对喜欢这一件。我的意思是，我觉得它对帕姆来说很完美。我们真的试图像角色那样去处理它。你知道，她怀孕了，她也在试图隐藏，她必须为之留出空间。所以我们选了A字裙，公主剪裁，这件前面还有一点点，你叫它什么，薄纱还是什么的？是的，就像用来隐藏你需要隐藏的东西的布料。
you need to hide. Yeah, we were like, this is perfect. I tried the dresses on with my little pregnancy bump belly. And then I actually contributed something to Pam's wedding outfit, which is her wedding necklace. There's a really good shot of it at eight minutes and 14 seconds in the scene. I had gone to like a jewelry art show, you know, those like an art fair and they sell jewelry and are you kidding? I love an art fair in the park. Get out of town. Yeah. And this woman was selling jewelry and I loved this necklace and it was made out of these crystals and it had a meaning behind it where it was supposed to bring you like peace and good luck. And when I saw it, I was kind of like, would Pam wear this on
是的，我们当时想，这太完美了。我穿着我的小孕肚试穿了这些婚纱。然后我实际上为帕姆的婚礼装扮做出了贡献，那就是她的结婚项链。在场景中8分14秒处有一个非常好的特写。我曾去过一个珠宝艺术展，你知道那种艺术集市，他们卖珠宝，你在开玩笑吗？我喜欢公园里的艺术集市。别开玩笑了。是的。那个女人在卖珠宝，我喜欢这条项链，它是用这些水晶制成的，它背后有一个含义，据说能给你带来平静和好运。当我看到它时，我当时想，帕姆会在她的婚礼上戴这个吗？所以我就把它带给艾丽西亚，她批准了，制片人也批准了，然后我们买了两条项链，我留了一条。
her wedding day? And so I brought it into Alicia and she approved it and the producers approved it and then we bought two necklaces and I kept one. Aw, that's so sweet. Yeah, because you know, we always have to have a double. So yeah, that's the story behind Pam's wedding dress. Well, I think we should take a break because when we come back, Jim and Pam are going to run off. I know it's true and we'll have a lot to say about that. All right, we're back and Pam calls Jim on the phone and she's like, will you come meet me in my dressing room? And he's kind of like, um, is that allowed? Is that okay? She's like, I'm allowing it. You know, lady, I got curious about this as this happens about this tradition
啊，太甜了。是的，因为你知道，我们总是需要一个替身。所以，这就是帕姆婚纱背后的故事。好吧，我想我们应该休息一下，因为回来后，吉姆和帕姆就要私奔了。我知道这是真的，我们对此有很多话要说。好了，我们回来了，帕姆给吉姆打电话，她说，你能来我的更衣室见我吗？他有点像，嗯，这允许吗？这可以吗？她说，我允许。你知道，女士，我对这个传统感到好奇，因为这发生了
of not seeing the bride before the wedding. Yeah. Did you look it up? I did. It's totally sexist. Do you want to hear it? Is it because there were arranged marriages and they didn't want guys to bail if they didn't find the person attractive? That's 100% right. That was just a guess. Yes. I think that's also why women had to wear a veil. Yes. And that's why you didn't lift the veil until after they said you were married. Okay. They also like made up the whole like, you know what? We got it. We got it. It's bad luck to see her before the wedding. It's bad luck. It was just like, it's totally made up. So anyway, everyone who's been worried about seeing your brighter groom before the wedding or being
婚礼前不见新娘的传统。是的。你查过了吗？我查了。这完全是性别歧视。你想听吗？是因为以前有包办婚姻，他们不想让男人在发现对方长得不吸引人时逃跑吗？完全正确。那只是个猜测。是的。我想这也是为什么女性必须戴面纱的原因。是的。这就是为什么直到他们说你们结婚后你才掀开面纱。好吧。他们还编造了整个，你知道吗？我们明白了。我们明白了。婚礼前见到她会倒霉。会倒霉。这完全是编造的。所以，总之，所有担心在婚礼前见到新娘或新郎的人，或者
afraid that you've created some sort of bad luck, you're off the hook. You're fine. You can go ahead and take those pictures before the ceremony. It's okay. We also got a fan question about this little scene, Angela, because Jim is playing soccer and Karen Kay from Pennsylvania would like to know, did Charles Miner soccer obsession rub off on Jim? Because I was very surprised to see him playing soccer with the little boy on his wedding day. I thought this was such a sweet scene. And Greg shared with us that Mindy really loves romantic comedies and she wanted this moment. She wanted Jim in the courtyard with like a young wedding guest, kicking the soccer ball around, you know, sort of that pre-wedding
害怕自己会带来某种厄运的人，你们不用担心了。你们没问题。你们可以继续在仪式前拍那些照片。没关系。我们还收到了关于这个小场景的粉丝提问，安吉拉，因为吉姆在踢足球，来自宾夕法尼亚州的凯伦·K想知道，查尔斯·迈纳对足球的痴迷是否影响了吉姆？因为看到他在婚礼当天和一个小男孩踢足球，我感到非常惊讶。我觉得这是一个非常温馨的场景。格雷格和我们分享说，明迪真的很喜欢浪漫喜剧，她想要这个时刻。她想要吉姆在庭院里和一个年轻的婚礼客人一起踢足球，你知道，那种婚礼前的
nerves and he's out there just hanging out. And it was really important to Mindy. She wanted this moment. Well, lady, when Jim gets to Pam's room, she's totally crying. Like she tore her veil. She thinks she looks terrible because she got no sleep. She's five months pregnant. She knows way too much about Andy scrotum. Yes. She feels like, I don't know, this day is just not going how she wanted. I remember I had to really work myself up because I wanted this emotion to feel really genuine. And I mean, we filmed this scene so many times. I feel like I was crying for like two hours. It was like, I had a headache afterwards.
紧张感，他就在外面闲逛。这对明迪来说真的很重要。她想要这个时刻。好吧，女士，当吉姆到达帕姆的房间时，她完全在哭。就像她撕破了面纱。她认为自己看起来很糟糕，因为她没睡好。她怀孕五个月了。她对安迪的阴囊了解得太多了。是的。她觉得，我不知道，这一天并没有按照她想要的方式进行。我记得我必须真正调动自己的情绪，因为我希望这种情感感觉非常真实。我的意思是，我们拍摄这个场景太多次了。我觉得我哭了大约两个小时。就像，之后我头疼。
Like it was really intense day of acting for me. This scene is so beautiful. I thought you and John both crushed it. Well, it's in this scene where Jim is going to try to make things better by cutting his tie to kind of prove to Pam that this day can be perfect without everything being perfect. Right. It doesn't matter about the tie. It doesn't matter about the veil. It just matters they're getting married. And Greg shared in his interview that this was based on a kind of real life event of a friend of his. It's really sweet. And like I said earlier, we did a lot of takes of this.
就像对我来说这是非常紧张的一天表演。这个场景太美了。我觉得你和约翰都演得太棒了。好吧，就在这个场景中，吉姆试图通过剪掉他的领带让事情变得更好，以向帕姆证明，即使没有一切都完美，这一天也可以是完美的。对。领带不重要。面纱不重要。重要的是他们要结婚了。格雷格在采访中分享说，这是基于他朋友的一个真实事件。真的很甜。就像我之前说的，我们拍了很多次。
We wanted to get it just right. We ended up doing like seven takes of this scene, but we ran out of ties. We didn't have a ton of ties, Angela. And so what we did was John would snip just the bottom of the tie. And then on the next take, he would go a little higher in the middle. So he just kept climbing up the tie. Yes. And if you look at 10 minutes, six seconds, you can see that the bottom of his tie is already cut off. It goes by really fast. But if you pause it, you can tell.
我们想把它拍得恰到好处。我们最终拍了大约七次这个场景，但我们的领带用完了。我们没有很多领带，安吉拉。所以我们做的是，约翰只剪掉领带的底部。然后在下一次拍摄时，他会往中间剪高一点。所以他一直在往上剪领带。是的。如果你看10分6秒，你可以看到他的领带底部已经被剪掉了。它过得很快。但如果你暂停它，你能看出来。
Well they decide to kind of elope in the middle of their wedding day. They run off. It's a beautiful shot. Beautiful shot. Greg said in the commentary, that's a nod to the movie The Graduate. I can see it. And of course, right behind them is Meredith smoking a cigar. Yes. Now everyone is inside the church and they're just waiting. The ceremony isn't starting. Everyone has opinions. There are so many little vignettes here, little different clumpings of people being chatty,
好吧，他们决定在婚礼当天私奔。他们跑了。这是一个美丽的镜头。美丽的镜头。格雷格在评论中说，那是对电影《毕业生》的致敬。我能看出来。当然，在他们身后是抽着雪茄的梅雷迪斯。是的。现在每个人都在教堂里，他们只是在等待。仪式还没有开始。每个人都有意见。这里有这么多小片段，不同的人群在聊天，
being snarky, wondering where Jim and Pam are. The cutest, I think, is Michael, who is very hungry, asked Pam's mom for a snack. Well there are a few I want to point out. Number one, at 13 minutes, nine seconds, when Dwight walks up to a sleeping Toby, he's laying down, you know, in the church pew, did you notice it looks like Toby is in a coffin the way it's framed at the top? I did not. Was that on purpose? I noticed that. And then when I listened to the commentary, that was on purpose. Paul Feig said that. So if you go back and look, I'll put it in stories. It cracked me
在讽刺，想知道吉姆和帕姆在哪里。我认为最可爱的是迈克尔，他非常饿，向帕姆的妈妈要零食。好吧，有几个我想指出的。第一，在13分9秒，当德怀特走到熟睡的托比身边时，他躺在教堂的长椅上，你注意到它看起来像托比躺在棺材里吗，从顶部的构图来看？我没注意到。那是故意的吗？我注意到了。然后当我听评论时，那是故意的。保罗·费格说的。所以如果你回去看，我会把它发到故事里。它让我笑
up. Also, there were more, Jenna. There were way more scenes while we all waited for Jim and Pam. Did you know that Angela tells a joke to Oscar and Kevin? No. Oh yeah, she thinks she's real funny. And she even talks about her inspiration for comedy. We have to hear it. Wait, do you two want to sit next to each other? Wait, was that you trying to be funny? I saw the funniest comedian one morning. Her name is Kelly Ripa. She's unrestrained. She
了。还有更多，珍娜。在我们等待吉姆和帕姆的时候，还有更多的场景。你知道安吉拉给奥斯卡和凯文讲了个笑话吗？不知道。哦，是的，她认为自己真的很幽默。她甚至谈到了她的喜剧灵感。我们必须听听。等等，你们两个想坐在一起吗？等等，那是你想表现得幽默吗？我有一天早上看到了最有趣的喜剧演员。她的名字叫凯利·里帕。她不受约束。她
will say anything. Oh my gosh. Angela is a huge Kelly Ripa fan. Who knew? She's a huge Kelly Ripa fan. And when like they had me talk about her at the end, they wanted me to laugh and then just wave the camera off. Like I'm so tickled. I can't even talk anymore. Oh my gosh. I love that. I completely forgot that I had done that talking head. Well, Pam and Jim are just going to arrive back at the church. They're blissful. Pam's
什么都说。天哪。安吉拉是凯利·里帕的超级粉丝。谁知道呢？她是凯利·里帕的超级粉丝。当他们让我最后谈论她时，他们想让我笑，然后挥手让摄像机走开。就像我被逗乐了。我甚至不能再说话了。天哪。我喜欢那个。我完全忘记了我做过那个谈话头镜头。好吧，帕姆和吉姆就要回到教堂了。他们很幸福。帕姆的
veil is nowhere to be found. Her hair is up now. We're going to start the wedding processional. That's right. But all of a sudden, Jim's brother looks to the back pew in the church where Michael's seated. Michael gives him a nod. Jim's brother then signals to the organ player to stop. Then Jim's brother signals Dwight to get up. Dwight goes over to an iPod shuffle. It looks like some kind of device like that and hits play. Yes. And now we are going to see all of Jim and Pam's family and all of their coworkers from Dunder Mifflin dance down the aisle to Chris Brown's song forever. That is going to be intercut with footage of them getting married on the maid of a mist. We have this
面纱不见了。她的头发现在盘起来了。我们要开始婚礼游行了。没错。但突然，吉姆的兄弟看向教堂后排的长椅，迈克尔坐在那里。迈克尔对他点了点头。吉姆的兄弟然后示意管风琴手停止。然后吉姆的兄弟示意德怀特站起来。德怀特走到一个iPod shuffle旁边。看起来像某种那样的设备，然后按下播放。是的。现在我们将看到吉姆和帕姆的所有家人以及他们所有来自邓德·米夫林的同事随着克里斯·布朗的歌《Forever》跳着舞走下过道。这将与他们在雾中少女号上结婚的镜头交替出现。我们有这个
big beautiful wedding montage. It's so joyous. Let's start by breaking down this dance number. Let's do it. This was the idea that they had to replace the horse. And I am so glad they did because this is so cute. This dance was a remake of a viral YouTube video. This couple, Jill and Kevin danced down the aisle at their real wedding along with their wedding party and our writers saw it and they thought this is what we should do. We should redo this dance video because they thought Michael would see this and this would be something he would think is super cool to recreate. And I guess in real life couples were recreating this
盛大美丽的婚礼蒙太奇。太欢乐了。让我们从拆解这段舞蹈开始吧。开始吧。这是他们用来代替马的想法。我很高兴他们这么做了，因为这太可爱了。这段舞蹈是翻拍自一个病毒式传播的YouTube视频。这对夫妇，吉尔和凯文在他们真正的婚礼上和他们的婚礼派对一起跳着舞走下过道，我们的编剧看到了，他们想这就是我们应该做的。我们应该重拍这个舞蹈视频，因为他们认为迈克尔会看到这个，这会是他认为超级酷的重现。我想在现实生活中，情侣们都在他们的婚礼上重现这个
viral video at their weddings. Oh yeah. Everybody knew about this video. Everyone had seen it. It never fails to make me smile. And Greg shared in the commentary that the cast in particular really wanted to end on an up note for Jim and Pam. Yeah. We wanted it to be a happy day. They had had so many things thrown their way. And this joyous moment really checked everyone's boxes. I found the original website for this wedding dance and the real couple, the woman Jill
病毒式视频。哦，是的。每个人都知道这个视频。每个人都看过。它总是让我微笑。格雷格在评论中分享说，演员们特别想为吉姆和帕姆画上一个圆满的句号。是的。我们希望这是一个快乐的日子。他们经历了这么多事情。而这个欢乐的时刻真的满足了每个人的愿望。我找到了这个婚礼舞蹈的原始网站，那对真正的夫妇，那个女人吉尔
is now a forensic psychologist and associate professor of criminal justice. Her husband Kevin is an immigration attorney who owns his own firm in St. Paul, Minnesota. Their video has over 100 million views. They have a whole website dedicated to their video. And they said that when they did it on their wedding day, it was a total surprise to everyone in the church. The pastor knew, but no one else knew. And they only posted it on YouTube because they wanted to share it with the friends and family who couldn't come to the wedding. They did not like intend for this to be shared widely. It was also during a time on the internet and YouTube in particular before we understood
现在是一名法医心理学家和刑事司法副教授。她的丈夫凯文是一名移民律师，在明尼苏达州圣保罗拥有自己的律师事务所。他们的视频有超过1亿次的观看量。他们有一个专门为他们的视频建立的网站。他们说，当他们在婚礼当天做这件事时，这对教堂里的每个人来说都是一个完全的惊喜。牧师知道，但没有其他人知道。他们只是把它发布在YouTube上，因为他们想与那些不能来参加婚礼的朋友和家人分享。他们并没有打算让它被广泛传播。那也是在互联网和YouTube特别是在我们理解之前的一个时期
how things could quote unquote go viral. Yes. They said within 48 hours of posting their video, they were flying to New York to be on the Today Show that it was just a total wild ride. They also said that they had no idea that we were going to recreate it on the office. And Randy Cordray said we did not like call them or tell them. They said they just saw it on TV. They said they nearly passed out when they saw the episode. They were fans of the office. But after the episode aired, we did send them a big photo of the cast dancing down the aisle that we all autographed. And Jill has it in her office at work today. And I think the coolest thing
事情如何“病毒式传播”。是的。他们说在发布视频后的48小时内，他们就飞往纽约参加《今日秀》，那真是一场疯狂的旅程。他们还说，他们根本不知道我们会在《办公室》里重现它。兰迪·科德雷说我们没有打电话给他们或告诉他们。他们说他们只是在电视上看到的。他们说当他们看到那一集时差点晕过去。他们是《办公室》的粉丝。但在那一集播出后，我们确实给他们寄了一张我们所有人签名的演员跳舞走下过道的照片。吉尔今天把它挂在她的办公室里。我认为最酷的事情
about this couple, I have to say, you know, they're still married. They have three kids now, two boys and a girl. And they used the popularity of this video to raise over $70,000 for charity. And so if you go to their website, they have a place where you can donate. So we're going to post all that because they are a pretty cool couple. They really are. We tried to find you guys. We tried to reach out. We wanted to talk to you today. We sent you an email through your website. We did. If you maybe don't check it that often, but we're in there. We're in there. We just want to say thank you for sharing such a special part of your wedding that brings joy to so many people, including office fans,
关于这对夫妇，我必须说，你知道，他们仍然结婚。他们现在有三个孩子，两个男孩和一个女孩。他们利用这个视频的流行度为慈善机构筹集了超过7万美元。所以如果你去他们的网站，他们有一个你可以捐款的地方。所以我们会发布所有这些，因为他们是一对非常酷的夫妇。他们确实是。我们试图找到你们。我们试图联系。我们今天想和你们谈谈。我们通过你们的网站给你们发了电子邮件。我们发了。如果你可能不经常查看它，但我们在那里。我们在那里。我们只是想说谢谢你们分享了你们婚礼中如此特别的一部分，它给很多人带来了快乐，包括《办公室》的粉丝，
Paul Feig shared that the background performers that filled out the rest of everyone attending the wedding, you know, the attendance and all the different pews, they were having so much fun watching us. He didn't even give direction. It was just pure joy. They were laughing and cheering. And he just let everyone's natural reactions play out. Vada shared that her and Paul Feig both began to cry when they watched us all dance down the aisle because there was just so much love and happiness in that moment. I feel it whenever we watch it. You know, I have to say I was really bummed because Pam is at the back of the church the
保罗·费格分享说，填补婚礼其余部分的背景表演者，你知道，出席者和所有不同的长椅上的人，看着我们玩得太开心了。他甚至没有给指导。那纯粹是快乐。他们在大笑和欢呼。他只是让每个人的自然反应表现出来。瓦达分享说，当她和保罗·费格看着我们所有人跳舞走下过道时，他们都开始哭了，因为那一刻有太多的爱和幸福。每当我们看它时，我都能感觉到。你知道，我必须说我真的很沮丧，因为帕姆在教堂的后面
whole time. So I did not really get to see that until it aired. I could just see you guys from behind. So I couldn't see your faces. And I remember thinking, John is so lucky that he's at the front of the church. Aw, I never thought about that, lady. I remember standing back there with you before it was my turn. Yeah, yeah. Well, Mary Ann Kellogg, who choreographed Cafe Disco, also helped choreograph the dancing down the aisle. Parts of it were choreographed and part was like freestyle, you know, a little
一直。所以我直到它播出才真正看到。我只能从后面看到你们。所以我看不到你们的脸。我记得当时想，约翰真幸运，他在教堂的前面。啊，我从来没想过那个，女士。我记得在轮到我之前和你站在后面。是的，是的。好吧，为《咖啡迪斯科》编舞的玛丽·安·凯洛格也帮助编排了走下过道的舞蹈。部分是编排的，部分是自由发挥的，你知道，一点点
bit of a combination. I remember talking to Paul Feig about Angela Martin and we both sort of felt like she wouldn't dance in a church. Yeah. And yet she would want to participate if everyone was participating. She wouldn't just be sitting in a pew watching. So I said to him, what if Angela Martin walks down clutching her purse because I also don't think she'd leave her purse unattended. These are great details. Yeah. So he really liked that. And so that's why Angela Martin just walks down the aisle
组合。我记得和保罗·费格谈论安吉拉·马丁，我们都觉得她不会在教堂里跳舞。是的。然而，如果每个人都参与，她会想参与。她不会只是坐在长椅上看。所以我对他说，如果安吉拉·马丁紧紧抓着她的钱包走下过道怎么样，因为我也不认为她会把钱包无人看管。这些细节太棒了。是的。所以他真的很喜欢那个。这就是为什么安吉拉·马丁只是走下过道
looking at everyone holding her purse. We got a fan question from Peyton H. in Vermont who said, how many takes did you do to get this right? You guys, it was one take. Randy Cordray shared with us that because this was such a last minute idea and we had so little time at the church, we only had enough time to do this dance scene twice. We could do two takes of it, but everybody nailed it on the first take. So we moved on. I was also in touch, Lady, with Tug Coker who plays one of Jim's brothers and he has a crazy story about doing this dance sequence. So here's the thing, we did one full take,
看着每个人，手里拿着她的钱包。我们收到了来自佛蒙特州佩顿·H的粉丝提问，她说，你们拍了多少次才拍好？你们，这是一次拍摄。兰迪·科德雷和我们分享说，因为这是一个最后一分钟的想法，我们在教堂的时间太少了，我们只有足够的时间把这个舞蹈场景拍两次。我们可以拍两次，但每个人在第一次拍摄时就做到了。所以我们继续了。女士，我也和饰演吉姆兄弟之一的塔格·科克联系过，他有一个关于做这个舞蹈序列的疯狂故事。所以事情是这样的，我们做了一次完整的拍摄，
like one running long take of this, but within that we did several takes of each bit. Right. We would reset really quickly depending on who was in the aisle. Yes. So Paul Feig, I guess, told Tug, here's what I want you to do. I want you to dance down the aisle and then once you're off camera, run around the back outside of the church through the courtyard, back to the front of the church and go down the aisle again. That's right. We had to do that, you guys, as soon as we did our individual pass, then we had to run back so we could do the group pass. So Tug said he did a couple of laps where he just danced individually down the aisle
就像一次长镜头拍摄，但在那之中我们对每个部分都拍了几次。对。我们会根据谁在过道里很快地重置。是的。所以保罗·费格，我想，告诉塔格，这就是我想要你做的。我想要你跳舞走下过道，然后一旦你离开镜头，跑回教堂外面的庭院，回到教堂前面，再次走下过道。没错。我们不得不那样做，你们，一旦我们完成了我们的个人通过，我们就必须跑回去，这样我们才能做集体通过。所以塔格说他跑了几圈，他只是单独跳舞走下过道
and then they would hold and he would run and he would do his individual dance down the aisle and then he would run. And he said, and then he also had to run to get into the group formation. He said, well, one of the times when he turned the corner from the courtyard, he slipped in his dress shoes and he just wiped out in front of the whole cast. He said he almost took down Ed Helms. Oh no. He said he was in a lot of pain. He went to the doctor and found out he had badly sprained his wrist. He had to get a splint after we wrapped the episode. He must have been really hurting. Yes. He said he fell and he did that thing, you know, like where you're like, I'm fine. I'm fine. I'll just continue dancing down
然后他们会停下来，他会跑，他会做他个人的舞蹈走下过道，然后他会跑。他说，然后他还必须跑去进入集体队形。他说，好吧，有一次当他从庭院转弯时，他在礼服鞋里滑倒了，他在整个演员面前摔倒了。他说他差点撞倒埃德·赫尔姆斯。哦，不。他说他很痛苦。他去看医生，发现他的手腕严重扭伤了。我们在拍摄完这一集后，他不得不戴上夹板。他一定很疼。是的。他说他摔倒了，他做了那个动作，你知道，就像你觉得“我没事，我没事。我只是继续跳舞走下
the aisle. But like as soon as the take was over, he like went to the doctor and he was really hurt. So when we got back in touch, he was like, Jenna, Jenna, when you get to the Niagara episode, I've got a story. You got to hear this story. And listen, lady, tug wasn't the only person who wanted to tell us a story about dancing down the aisle at a wedding. We also got some fan mail from KS in Virginia. Here is what she said, I have been waiting for this episode to tell you ladies this great story. I was a bridesmaid in a wedding where the bride wanted us to dance into the reception like the office crew danced down the aisle at Jim and Pam's wedding. The other bridesmaids were not really into
过道”。但就像拍摄结束后，他去看医生，他真的受伤了。所以当我们重新联系时，他说，珍娜，珍娜，当你拍到尼亚加拉那一集时，我有一个故事。你必须听听这个故事。听着，女士，塔格不是唯一一个想告诉我们关于在婚礼上跳舞走下过道的故事的人。我们还收到了一些来自弗吉尼亚州KS的粉丝邮件。她是这么说的，我一直在等这一集告诉你们女士这个伟大的故事。我是一个婚礼的伴娘，新娘想让我们像《办公室》剧组在吉姆和帕姆的婚礼上跳舞走下过道那样跳进招待会。其他伴娘并不是很感兴趣
it, but being the office lover I am, I knew this was my moment to shine. I started by walking like Phyllis. Then I broke into Oscars pivot. Then I wanted to do the infamous Dwight kick, but my foot slipped and I fell immediately forward. My face broke my fall. Oh no. She said I was so embarrassed. I jumped right up, ran to the dance floor behind everyone. And as soon as the bride and groom came out, I ran to the bathroom because my face was covered in blood and I was missing my front tooth. Oh my gosh. But she said it was all for the love of the office. Oh my gosh. Kate, you waited so long to send us that piece of mail. I just had to read it. I am so sorry. But thank you. Thank you for sharing with
，但作为《办公室》的爱好者，我知道这是我闪耀的时刻。我开始像菲利斯那样走。然后我开始做奥斯卡的旋转。然后我想做臭名昭著的德怀特踢腿，但我的脚滑了，我立刻向前摔倒。我的脸摔在了地上。哦，不。她说我太尴尬了。我立刻跳起来，跑到每个人身后的舞池。当新娘和新郎出来时，我立刻跑进洗手间，因为我的脸满是血，我掉了一颗门牙。天哪。但她说这都是为了对《办公室》的爱。天哪。凯特，你等了这么久才给我们发那封邮件。我不得不读出来。我真的很抱歉。但谢谢你。谢谢你分享
us. Jenna, I feel like Kate needs an office ladies coffee mug. I mean, she lost her tooth. Yes. Yes. We have to send Kate a mug. Kate, we're sending you a mug. Thank you for your love of the office. Big hugs. Well, while all of this dancing is happening at the church, they cut back and forth between the church and Jim and Pam getting married on Made of the Mist. It just makes the whole moment that much more special. I loved it. I know, lady. Let me tell you now about the Made of the Mist. We kind of covered this a little bit with Greg, which is that we could only rent out the front of the boat. The rest of the boat was filled with paying customers. The other
给我们。珍娜，我觉得凯特需要一个《办公室》女士的咖啡杯。我的意思是，她掉了一颗牙。是的。是的。我们必须给凯特寄一个杯子。凯特，我们给你寄一个杯子。谢谢你对《办公室》的爱。大大的拥抱。好吧，当所有这些舞蹈在教堂发生时，他们在教堂和吉姆与帕姆在雾中少女号上结婚之间切换。这让整个时刻变得更加特别。我喜欢它。我知道，女士。现在让我告诉你关于雾中少女号的事。我们和格雷格稍微谈过这个，那就是我们只能租下船的前部。船的其余部分挤满了付费乘客。另一
thing was that we were in no way allowed to change the course of the boat or the length of the boat ride. So before we went out, Randy and Randall and Paul Feig had all scouted this boat trip. They rode the boat over and over again to see exactly when they wanted Jim and Pam to exchange vows to have the falls in the background, how long we had before the boat would turn everything. They sort of estimated that to cover it all, we would have to take eight boat trips. So they also realized that depending on the time of day, there would be spray coming off the falls. Like sometimes of day or depending on the wind, you got more spray. So when you get on the boat, everybody wears those like blue
件事是，我们绝不允许改变船的航向或船程的长度。所以在我们出发之前，兰迪和兰德尔以及保罗·费格已经勘察过这次船程。他们一次又一次地乘船，看看他们到底想让吉姆和帕姆在什么时候交换誓言，让瀑布作为背景，我们在船转弯前有多少时间等等。他们估计要覆盖这一切，我们必须进行八次船程。所以他们还意识到，根据一天中的时间，瀑布会有喷雾。就像一天中的某些时间或根据风向，你会得到更多的喷雾。所以当你上船时，每个人都穿着那些蓝色的
parkas. They give them to you with your ticket. Right, right. Like the ones you get at Disneyland. Exactly. When it's raining, everyone has their poncho on. Exactly. So they were like, okay, we'll have them wear their little ponchos. They'll take them off to go get the boat captain. That's super cute. They had it all figured out. Randall was like, listen, I am going to need to shoot on a film camera because the white falls are like really white. I'm not going to be able to color balance on a digital camera. That was like a whole extra thing, you know, to shoot on film instead of digital. But anyway, we were so limited in the number of people we could have in the front of the boat that Greg asked Randy Cordray,
派克大衣。他们会连同你的票一起给你。对，对。就像你在迪士尼乐园得到的那样。完全正确。下雨时，每个人都穿着雨披。完全正确。所以他们当时想，好吧，让他们穿上他们的小雨披。他们会脱掉它去见船长。这太可爱了。他们都想好了。兰德尔当时说，听着，我需要用胶片摄像机拍摄，因为白色的瀑布真的很白。我无法在数码摄像机上进行色彩平衡。那是一整件额外的事情，你知道，用胶片而不是数码拍摄。但总之，我们在船前部能容纳的人数非常有限，以至于格雷格要求兰迪·科德雷，
our line producer, to play the minister, the boat captain. So that's who you see marrying Jim and Pam. And it warms my heart to see him. I just love it so much. I know. I do too. It makes me so happy. But we also had a bunch of family members of our cast and crew in the front of the boat with us. Greg Daniels assistant, Mary Wall is from the area and her family volunteered to come ride the boat. That's right. If you listen to the DVD commentary, Mary is pointing out, she's like, that's my cousin. That's so and so like her whole family was in it. Also, Kelly Hannon, who is one of our writer's assistants, her family rode the boat. And then the craziest thing was that Brian Baumgartner's parents,
我们的制片经理，扮演牧师，船长。所以这就是你看到的为吉姆和帕姆主持婚礼的人。看到他让我感到心里暖暖的。我太喜欢它了。我知道。我也一样。这让我很高兴。但我们船的前部还有很多我们演员和工作人员的家人和我们在一起。格雷格·丹尼尔斯的助理，玛丽·沃尔来自那个地区，她的家人自愿来乘船。没错。如果你听DVD评论，玛丽指出来，她说，那是我的表弟。那是某某某，就像她的全家都在里面。此外，我们编剧助理之一凯利·汉农的家人也乘了船。然后最疯狂的事情是布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳的父母，
Bruce and Cherry, happened to be on vacation in Rochester, New York, and they told Brian they were going to visit Niagara Falls the same day we were shooting. This is so crazy. They actually just had this planned, unknowing that we were going to be there filming. Yes. Brian was like, well, you should stop by the set. So he texted us and we were like, oh my gosh. And then Paul Feig talked them into coming on the boat with us. They did not know what they were getting into. They are directly behind Jim and Pam as you guys walk on the boat. Yes. So let me just say, as we get out there, they warned us, you might get a little wet. Lady, lady, as we took our first trip to the falls, we're getting closer, a little
布鲁斯和切丽正好在纽约罗切斯特度假，他们告诉布莱恩，他们打算在我们拍摄的同一天去参观尼亚加拉大瀑布。这太疯狂了。他们其实早就计划好了，根本不知道我们会在那里拍摄。是的。布莱恩说，嗯，你们应该顺便来片场看看。于是他给我们发了短信，我们当时就想，天哪。然后保罗·费格说服他们和我们一起上了船。他们根本不知道自己要面对什么。当你们走上船时，他们就站在吉姆和帕姆的正后方。是的。所以让我说一下，当我们走出去时，他们警告我们，你们可能会弄湿一点。天哪，天哪，当我们第一次前往瀑布时，我们越来越近，有一点点
bit of spray. All of a sudden, like, I don't even know what to call it, like a tidal wave of water, like sheets of water hit me. Similar to the water cannon that hit me when I was an extra on the Universal Studios Jurassic Park ride, just like so much water. Kelly Cantley said on the DVD commentary, Jenna, it looked like someone took an enormous full giant tub of water and just doused you with it. She said they could not believe how drenched you got in a matter of seconds. You were drenched. I will never forget John Krasinski's face after whatever that was hit me, that spray hit me. He, I knew how wet I was because of how he was looking at me. He sort of turned to them like, are we, I mean, can we continue?
水雾。突然间，我甚至不知道该怎么形容，就像一股海啸般的水，像大片的水幕打在我身上。就像我在环球影城侏罗纪公园游乐设施当临时演员时打在我身上的水炮一样，水实在太多了。凯利·坎特利在DVD评论中说，珍娜，看起来就像有人拿了一个巨大无比的水桶，直接把你浇透了。她说他们简直不敢相信你在几秒钟内就湿透了。你全身都湿透了。我永远不会忘记约翰·卡拉辛斯基在那些水打在我身上，那些水雾打在我身上之后的表情。他，我知道我有多湿，因为他看着我的眼神。他转过头对他们说，我们，我是说，我们还能继续吗？
Like, is this, she looks like someone just tossed her over the side of the boat. Yes. My makeup was running down my face. So they just shot us from behind and actually for that trip. And you know that beautiful shot at the very end of the montage where my head is on John's shoulder. Yeah. That is because I could not turn around. Because you were so soaked. I was so soaked. So they brought us back to shore and they dried me off the best they could. Like on the side of the shore, they sent us back out again. The same thing happened again. They were like, Oh no, I don't know what to do. I guess this is what we have. Finally in the afternoon, we went out again, hoping like maybe, you know, like it'll be
就像是，她看起来就像有人刚把她从船边扔下去一样。是的。我的妆都顺着脸流下来了。所以他们只是从后面拍我们，实际上那次行程是这样。你知道蒙太奇最后那个美丽的镜头，我的头靠在约翰的肩膀上吗？是的。那是因为我没法转过身来。因为你湿透了。我湿透了。所以他们把我们带回岸边，尽他们所能把我擦干。就在岸边，他们又把我们送了出去。同样的事情又发生了。他们当时想，哦不，我不知道该怎么办。我想这就是我们能拍到的了。最后在下午，我们又出去了，希望也许，你知道，也许这次会
drier this time. And Randy got to talking to the real boat captain, who was like, your actors got pretty drenched this morning. And Randy was like, Yes, yes. But you know, we were told that you cannot change course at all. So we're going to deal with it. And the boat captain said, Who said that? I'm the captain of this ship. And I'm a huge fan of the office. I'll take you anywhere you want. What? And Randy was like, Wait, what? And he was like, That's right. He goes, I just won't get so close this time. So he he like stopped the boat. So you were out of like the splash zone. Yes. And that is how we ultimately were able to get a dry take. So crazy, right? Well, it all worked out because it's such
干一点。兰迪和真正的船长聊了起来，船长说，你们的演员今天早上湿透了。兰迪说，是的，是的。但你知道，我们被告知你们根本不能改变航线。所以我们只能应付了。船长说，谁说的？我是这艘船的船长。而且我是《办公室》的超级粉丝。我会带你们去任何你们想去的地方。什么？兰迪当时就想，等等，什么？他说，没错。他说，我只是这次不会靠得那么近。所以他停下了船。所以你们离开了溅水区。是的。这就是我们最终能够拍到干爽镜头的方法。太疯狂了，对吧？嗯，一切都很顺利，因为这是如此
beautiful footage. You know, there's one thing that did not work out. What? We got a fan question from April end and South Bend, Indiana, who noticed what's with the cheek kiss after the Made of the Mist ceremony. Did you notice that on Made of the Mist, John kisses me on my cheek and not my lips? Yeah, I do. And I was like, What's why? Why don't Jim and Pam want to kiss? Well, what's happening? I will tell you, John Krasinski had a terrible flu. Like, truly, you guys, he was running a fever. Like he showed up in hair and makeup that morning. And he was like, You know how like you're all clammy and glassy eyed? Yeah, when you're really sick. That was John. He was having a hard time keeping food down.
美丽的镜头。你知道，有一件事不太顺利。什么？我们收到了来自印第安纳州南本德的艾普丽尔·恩的一个粉丝提问，她注意到“雾中少女”仪式后的脸颊吻是怎么回事？你注意到在“雾中少女”号上，约翰亲吻了我的脸颊而不是嘴唇吗？是的，我注意到了。我当时想，为什么？为什么吉姆和帕姆不想接吻？嗯，发生了什么事？我告诉你，约翰·卡拉辛斯基得了严重的流感。真的，伙计们，他在发烧。那天早上他出现在化妆间时。他当时就像，你知道那种浑身湿冷、眼神呆滞的感觉吗？是的，当你病得很重的时候。那就是约翰。他很难吃下东西。
Oh my gosh. And I'm sure you guys were like, We only have one day here. What do you do? You have to rally. We had to shoot it. First of all, to John's credit, you would never know he was sick. He was so amazing. He was such a trooper. But he was really, really worried about giving me his flu. And he was kind of like, I am not going to kiss her on the lips and give her this flu. That is terrible. I won't do it. And I'm sure you were like, Thank you. I was. I was like, Okay, but we didn't know like, What are we going to do? So in editing, Claire had the idea that she would cut from the kind of fakey cheek kiss to a really good real kiss back at the church ceremony. And we just kind of hoped no one would notice.
天哪。我敢肯定你们当时想，我们在这里只有一天时间。该怎么办？你们必须振作起来。我们必须拍完它。首先，不得不说约翰很敬业，你根本看不出他生病了。他太棒了。他真是个硬汉。但他真的很担心把流感传染给我。他当时就像，我不能亲吻她的嘴唇，把流感传染给她。那太糟糕了。我不会那样做的。我敢肯定你当时想，谢谢你。我是这样想的。我当时想，好吧，但我们不知道该怎么办。所以在剪辑时，克莱尔想出了一个主意，她把那个假装的脸颊吻剪辑成教堂仪式上一个真正的好吻。我们只是希望没人会注意到。
It's true though, because everyone is waiting for that magical kiss after they say I do. Yeah. And the church one is such a good one. This all leads to this beautiful talking head by Jim. Greg shared with us that he assigned the talking head to Danny Chun. It's so lovely. I think we should hear it. I bought those boat tickets the day I saw that YouTube video. I knew we'd need to back up plan. The boat was actually plan C, the church was plan B, and plan A was marrying her a long, long time ago. Pretty much the day I met her. And Claire Scanlon, our editor, shared that she fought really hard to keep this talking head in. And she's shared maybe if it would have been one of the guys that might have gotten cut because
不过这是真的，因为每个人都在等待他们说“我愿意”之后那个神奇的吻。是的。教堂里的那个吻真是太棒了。这一切都引出了吉姆那段美丽的独白。格雷格告诉我们，他把这段独白分配给了丹尼·春。太可爱了。我想我们应该听听。我在看到那个YouTube视频的那天就买了船票。我知道我们需要一个备用计划。船实际上是C计划，教堂是B计划，而A计划是在很久很久以前就娶她。几乎是在我见到她的那天。我们的剪辑师克莱尔·斯坎伦分享说，她非常努力地争取保留这段独白。她说如果换成是其中一个男角色，可能就被剪掉了，因为
everyone did think the wedding ended on such a high note. But she just loved this talking head and I think it's so great that it stayed in. I get goosebumps every time. I just absolutely love it. And once again, our writers did that amazing thing they do where you go from this incredibly sweet moment to Kevin putting his feet in the ice machine at the hotel. And then to Michael and Pam's mom sneaking into a hotel room together. What? What? And that is how Niagara ends, you guys. Oh, wow. What fun rewatching this episode. Thank you once again to Greg Daniels. Thank you, Tug Coker, for your wonderful stories. Yes. And as always, Randy Cordray. Oh, my goodness. Thank you for all the details you shared with us. Enjoy about four for hooking
每个人都认为婚礼以如此高调的方式结束。但她就是喜欢这段独白，我觉得它能保留下来真是太好了。我每次听都会起鸡皮疙瘩。我绝对太喜欢它了。再一次，我们的编剧们做到了他们那种神奇的事情，你从这个极其甜蜜的时刻转到了凯文把脚放进酒店的制冰机里。然后转到迈克尔和帕姆的妈妈偷偷溜进酒店房间。什么？什么？这就是《尼亚加拉》的结局，伙计们。哦，哇。重温这一集真有趣。再次感谢格雷格·丹尼尔斯。谢谢塔格·科克，感谢你精彩的故事。是的。还有一如既往的兰迪·科德雷。哦，天哪。感谢你与我们分享的所有细节。感谢Enjoy About Four为我们
us up with Jim and Pam's amazing wedding website. And be sure to check our Office Ladies pod Instagram account, because we're going to be posting a bunch of fun stories to go with this episode. And if you listened to this a little late, just a reminder, there is an Instagram account called Office Ladies Stories. And the woman who runs the account will go and save our stories for us. We are so grateful. Yes. And that's it for Niagara. We'll see you next week. We hope you have a great one. Love you. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Ear Wolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam
提供了吉姆和帕姆精彩的婚礼网站。一定要查看我们的Office Ladies播客Instagram账号，因为我们将发布一系列与本集相关的有趣故事。如果你听得有点晚，提醒一下，有一个叫Office Ladies Stories的Instagram账号。经营该账号的女士会为我们保存我们的故事。我们非常感激。是的，这就是《尼亚加拉》的全部内容。我们下周见。希望你们过得愉快。爱你们。到时候见。感谢收听Office Ladies。Office Ladies由Ear Wolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆
Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
基弗，我们的助理制片人是安斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。如需无广告版本的Office Ladies，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。